foreign
the time being 9 A.M I'd like to welcome
all of you to the 2023 joint economic
briefing on behalf of house Ways and
Means and Senate ways and means we also
have in the audience most of the members
of house and maybe Senate Finance so
welcome everyone
I'm Lori Sam Warren and I'll just be
your moderator today in a normal hearing
we ask that our members don't open up
their laptops but today there's an
exception because I think we're going to
see some amazing presentations from some
of our agency heads so if you'd like to
open up your laptop so you can follow
along please feel free to do so at the
bottom of your agenda is the link to
reach all of these handouts that you'll
see on the screens or there's also an
email from jennifer4 and you can click
on that link there to follow along if
you'd like
so without further Ado I'd like to
introduce to you Michael Kane Michael
Kane is our legislative budget assistant
and I have a little bit of a bio to give
you on him he has been with the state of
New Hampshire legislative budget office
for 23 years and before that he was with
the state of Massachusetts budget
offices supporting house Ways and Means
Michael holds a master's degree in
public administration from Suffolk
University and a bachelor's degree in
political science and philosophy for
Merrimack College so welcome
thank you very much
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee
um so just a quick overview of the
legislative budget assistance office we
are a non-partisan office for the
general court uh we have 23 Auditors who
do financial and performance Auditors
and then we have seven members in the
budget division uh the budget division
is through who the legislature works
with on a regular basis uh will support
the house finance committees in the
center Finance committees the uh
house ways it means the Senate ways
means committees this along with the cat
along with the capital budget and Public
Works committees uh as far as our
support for the House and Senate Ways
and Means Committee you'll meet uh the
deputy LBA is Chris Shea so you'll have
a chance to meet him
um in general uh what Chris will do is
work with you throughout the House and
Senate Revenue estimating processes and
to help uh basically combine all the
information that you have based on your
discussions on where you think a general
and education trust fund Highway fund
and fiscal uh sorry fishing game Revenue
will go and then to put that into a
format to present to the house in a
resolution typically the house Ways and
Means Committee puts forth a house
resolution in usually in the February
March time frame based on
um you know how the committee is moving
forward that information is then
presented as a non-binding resolution to
the house who then votes on it that
information is communicated with the
finance committee so the house finance
committee behind me
they'll have a base Revenue estimate
which they will then be able to do their
work to create a budget for the next two
fiscal years so right now we're in
fiscal year 23 we're about to enter into
a budget process for the 24 and 25
biennial budget so our office really is
to you know communicate between the two
committees as well any bills that go
before the house ways means or Senate
Ways and Means committees that may have
an impact on the revenues in 24 and 25.
we ensure that we keep track of that in
a so-called Surplus statement which is
really just a catch-all of any bills or
legislation or changes that are
happening as the budget is being
developed and that is to ensure that
there's a balanced budget at the end of
the biennium
so that's basically a quick overview of
what we do do feel free to reach out to
any member of my staff or myself during
the session I know we have a lot of
returning members we have a lot of new
members our office is over in the state
house in Room 101 and 102 so feel free
at any time
just to show you before
um before the budget starts
there's a lot of uncertainty of kind of
how the current fiscal year is going to
end we're in fiscal year 23 we're six
months through that fiscal year a little
into our seventh month
you've heard in the paper that you know
the state had a
a record Surplus say over 400 million
dollars over Revenue they had almost 361
million dollars that they ended their
fiscal year with for 22 which closed in
June
um what does that mean and how does that
impact the budget process and the
revenue estimates going forward
so what we usually provide is an uh a
snapshot so this is a point in time
snapshot of where we are today and I can
guarantee that these numbers on this
page other than the top one which is a
an audited final number of on row two of
361.3 million dollars of the balance
that we begin with in 23. all the
numbers will change
um
so just kind of take where we are
361.3 million dollars to begin the year
for 23. during the budget negotiations
in 21 of the budget deliberations that
estimate of the 22 balance coming
forward into for education and journal
fund was estimated at 67 million dollars
so almost 300 plus million dollar
variants of the beginning balance uh
majority of that most of that has to do
with uh performance of revenue revenue
for the last fiscal year which results
in the circles is almost 400 plus
million dollars over what the
legislatures had assumed
um and you do I just wanted to remind
everyone when the budget Revenue
estimates were established we were just
coming out of uh covet pandemic shutdown
20 FY 20 actually had a negative balance
and so there was a lot of uncertainty on
how the next two years next three years
would really carry out
um and so although the revenue estimates
in hindsight uh were lower than what
actually occurred it's just to remember
kind of the pressures on the legislature
back in 21 when they were trying to
determine really an uncertain path
forward for Revenue estimates which
sometimes is results in a change or a
variance in your revenues
estimated Revenue
um on row five in the budget 2.69
billion dollars and that's between both
the uh general fund and the education
trust fund General funds about 1.65
close to 1.7 million of that uh the
year-to-date variance So based on the
December monthly Revenue Focus which is
a report that administrative Services uh
monitors
Revenue with during the year based on
the December monthly Revenue Focus the
state is already
207.1 million dollars up and you are
halfway through your fiscal year
so the total revenue for the year
estimated at about
2.898.4 million if we assume that from
this point forward we continue to hit
plan but you're going to receive monthly
Revenue focuses for every month you're
going to receive uh the next couple week
months uh updates from Commissioners on
where they think the revenues are going
to perform for the remainder of the
fiscal year
um so that 207 million dollars what we
know now but that number could go up
um or it could go down and the reason I
say that is March and April are big
Revenue months for collections
especially business taxes June as well
there are several changes made to the
business taxes over the last few years
and I think commissioner stepp will talk
about it when dra is here
um but March and April a really big
Revenue months and or something that the
house will not have necessarily when
you're providing your estimates so
you're going to have regular
conversations with dra in some of the
larger Revenue collections collecting
agencies to make your determination
where you think first where is 23 going
to end and then that's going to be kind
of your launching that's going to be
your start for predicting 24 and 25
going forward you have a lot of
economists coming in a lot of very smart
people coming in who have been here for
several years who can kind of you know
help you to identify areas that you
should keep an eye on when you're trying
to predict two years out and there's
nowhere to no way to figure out what's
going to happen so it's a best case
scenario
but it is a budget process it is just
based on estimates
um and so Finance again once those
estimates are done finance will create
their budget
so for Appropriations the budget
Appropriations about 2.794 million
dollars it's a little above the 2.7905
uh that was in the committee conference
budget a lot of that has to do with uh
timing of when the Appropriations are
actually applied 22 versus 23.
unbudgeted appropriations of 30.9
million so separate from the budget
process house the state also has
statutory Appropriations or
Appropriations approved through fiscal
in certain instances that are a draw
against the general or education trust
fund a couple of those items are your
attorney general litigation funds which
are averaging about 8 million over the
last couple of years you have your
judicial Council engine defense uh
funding that comes through fiscal
committee that I believe they may have
another request before the end of the
year but that usually averages between
two and three million dollars a year you
have your education Freedom accounts
which uh you'll know that I think it was
estimated about 15 million dollars or
twenty three is where that's going to
maybe end up and then row 12 it's not
usually a line that you'll see a lot a
lot of times when we do a snapshot the
state hasn't been in a situation where
our Revenue has been so high that the
legislature
had had the ability to basically
appropriate funds for specific projects
so over the last of the 2022 session
there's probably
um
close to 275 to 300 million dollars of
Appropriations that went out and that
was based on the revenue Surplus so they
knew the governor and the legislature
knew that Revenue was exceeding plan
they knew that the expenditures were in
line with where they were estimating and
so they had legislative specials or
specific bills 67 million dollars for
highways you have some adequate
education changes about 14 million
dollars for one bill
that had passed through extraordinary
need grants is what they're called and
then some retirement one-time costs or
to help with the community some
additional Aid that the legislature and
Governor really wanted to make one-time
Appropriations since they did have those
funds available
so in total in 23 we know although we
carried forward about 361.3 million uh
there's almost 270 million of it between
the unbudgeted Appropriations and the
legislative specials that are already
accounted it's already been spent
basically uh but even then you do have
your 200 million dollar Revenue Surplus
so far uh we have an estimated lapse
which is basically uh unspent funds so
the legislature will appropriate two
years ahead of time not all those funds
are spent and when they build the budget
the finance committees will incorporate
a lapse and the lapse happens because of
unfilled positions and we know the state
has a high vacancy rate because of uh
projections that are vary from what was
initially estimated so you do estimated
about a 90 million 89.5 million dollar
lapse which the state has been able to
meet the last several years they've
actually come in over 40 million for 22
over the laps if you go back to 20 21
there are almost 100 million over where
they thought the estimated lapse was for
various reasons so
and that will bring you to your
cumulative ending balance on Row 18
which is about
282.8 million dollars
that's both General and education trust
fund the education trust fund Surplus
just based on these numbers which will
change is approximately 99.4 million
dollars the remainder being the second
year of the biennium the odd year the
remainder based on statute would go into
the rainy day fund So based on what we
know now on row 21 just using the
calculations of the rainy day fund
183.4 million dollars would go into
their any day fund now you all know
people who have been here
representatives and Senators who have
been know that that's going to be a big
discussion during the budget process not
only does the budget process
appropriate funds for the next two
fiscal years but they also look at is
there Surplus in the current fiscal year
and then make a decision do we let it
all go into the rainy day fund do we
appropriate it for one-time needs do we
maybe help with our tax burden uh for
you know and make some changes in taxes
it really comes down to what is the
governor in the legislature comfortable
with for that rainy day fund balance and
over the last couple years that's been
about 150 million dollars the cap on the
rainy day fund is over 400 million
dollars if and that's just a rough
estimate we knew we brought in about two
billion dollars of or a little under two
billion dollars last year in general
funds the cap is two years of general
fund revenues for the current Pioneer
assuming we get the same two billion
dollars that Cap's going to be around
400 million comes out to about 380 but
you also have settlement money that goes
in there that adds to that cap so
roughly about 400 million
um if the rainy day fund does hit that
cap then any additional funds
automatically carry over to the next
fiscal year so they'd stay into the
journal fund
so that will be a definitely discussion
I'm sure the governors right now is
developing the budget uh his crack at
the budget with the agencies right now
and I'm sure they're discussing what
they think uh the rainy day fund balance
should be you'll hear from many people
whether States rainy day fund balance
should be and what's the proper level
but it's really up to the legislature
and Governor to come up that level that
you're comfortable with of surplus funds
you're holding on hand
um
and so that's kind of uh where we are
now uh just to point out I should have
pointed out for it education trust fund
does not lapse so it's a non-lapsing
fund we've gone several years with uh
carrying balances forward in the
education trust fund there was uh you
know since its Inception there were
general fund transfers into the fund
because by Statute any deficit in the
education trust fund are filled with a
general fund but right now we're in a
good position so there's almost 108
million dollars carried forward from 22
into 23 which is part of that 361 up top
but based on the projected level of
spending in the education trust one
the revenue just through December that
balance will stay right around 100
million dollars obviously that's going
to change based on Final adequacy counts
and final Revenue numbers
um but again that balance carries
forwards into 24 and 25 for education
so I'll stop there
um don't want to overload you with too
much but usually what we'll see is our
office as we receive the monthly Revenue
focuses as we receive
um you know the estimates from the waste
means Community House ways Means
Committee as bills start passing and
moving through the communities you'll
start to see this snapshot morph into
something that will be more of a
snapshot for the finance chairs as they
go forward to develop their budget
what's out there what's changing where
are we now and then when the governor
releases his Budget on February 15th is
the deadline or is the statutory
required date of February 15th we'll
have a first glimpse of what's the
um the first plan on 24 and 25 as 23 24
and 25 and then we'll work with finance
and uh Senate the House and Senate
Finance over the next several months
so
hope that helps I'll kind of stop there
if uh but I can answer any questions
that you have sure
representative Platt yes thank you this
is ignorance because I'm new to Ways and
Means who's how was the 400 million
dollar rainy day fund cap set is that
legislation
it is it's RSA
913e
it's a calculated statutory cap
and so that was actually just changed
two sessions Ago by the legislature it
used to be one year general fund
revenues
um and it was changed this to uh the
biennium ago to be two years of general
fund Revenue so statute but subjects the
legislative change
yep
again please thank you madam chair I'm
almost afraid to ask this question
because maybe I'm missing something but
when I look at the total revenue of 2.8
and subtract the appropriations of 2.97
I would get a negative cumulative ending
balance so I know I'm missing something
because you get 282. sure so the total
year balance so the current year balance
is negative
um if you add the preliminary balance up
on Row 2 to the um your total revenue of
the 2898 that will bring you to the
three-point roughly 3.2 billion then
subtract your 297 six point that we did
have the cumulative ending balance of
282 which is still positive but if you
look at just the current year it would
be negative because the legislature had
planned for a big balance forward
is that all you have for today
we're going to see more of you so you'll
see a lot of us yes thank you so much
next up we have the commissioner of dras
welcome commissioner
good morning and Lindsey stepp has been
the commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of Revenue Administration
since December of 2017 and previously
served as assistant commissioner of the
dra as well as a financial analyst she
became her she began her career it says
at ey
Ernest and Young is that that's okay as
an international tax and transfer
pricing consultant and she received her
masters of business administration
degree from Plymouth State and her
Bachelor of Science degree in economics
from Trinity College in Hartford Thank
you very much for coming
thank you madam chair good morning
members of the committee Lindsey stepp
commissioner New Hampshire Department
Revenue Administration
you should all have a presentation in
front of you it's also showing on the
screen
I'm going to walk through today
um
with you kind of What dra does the taxes
that we collect and kind of the current
yeah so sorry just so everybody get
there that's the first page should look
okay
all right
so first
the Department of Revenue Administration
we administer 14 taxes for the State of
New Hampshire uh representing about 2.6
billion dollars which is just over 80
percent of the general and education
trust funds for fiscal year 22. so we
are the main Revenue collecting Agency
for the general fund and education trust
fund
we do have important insights that we'll
share with you today about the
performance of the state's most
significant Revenue sources but we lack
the capacity to form perform more
complex economic predictions but you
have a wonderful slate of people to hear
from over the next day and a half so
we'll kind of cue everything up for you
give you where we are year to date with
revenues factors that we see affecting
the various taxes and what we're seeing
in terms of a trend versus plan and then
when you hear from the rest of the
economists and other experts over the
next couple days you'll have a nice
Foundation
so we're going to go tax by tax I'll
stop Madam chair at the end of each tax
if that's okay to answer any questions
okay so first we have the meals and
rentals tax or m r as we refer to it m r
is levied on consumers for the purchase
of taxable meals accommodation rentals
and motor vehicle rentals the tax rate
was nine percent through September 30th
of 2021 and then lowered to eight and a
half percent on October 1st of 2021.
the taxes collected by the operator the
restaurant owner the hotel owner and
then remitted to dra on a monthly basis
School building a Debt Service is paid
out of m r every month the transfer was
14.6 million in fiscal 2012 but has been
decreasing over more recent years to 8.1
million in 22 and currently 7 million in
2023.
looking at m r Revenue over the past few
years we have seen a rebound since uh
covid-19 when obviously a lot of
restaurants and hotels were closed so we
saw a hit to m r Revenue during that
time but since everything has been open
again we did see an almost 10 percent
decrease in 2020 from 2019 due to the
shutdowns related to covid but when
restaurants and hotels opened back up we
saw a 6.1 percent increase in 21 over 20
and then we've seen a 21.7 increase in
22 over 21 before taking into account
the municipal Revenue fund transfer
so in
um starting in fiscal 21 nope I'm sorry
fiscal 22. on a monthly basis we
transfer Revenue into a municipal
Revenue fund
the purpose of that is to send
approximately 30 of m r Revenue back to
the cities and towns so we do that
transfer on a monthly basis so when
you're looking at net m r or m r that's
in the general fund in 22 and comparing
it it'll actually look like revenues
went down
they didn't gross revenues actually went
up from 21 to 22 but because of the
municipal transfer into the restricted
account it'll look like a decrease when
you're looking at just the general fund
portion
so for fiscal 23 our current fiscal year
actual revenue for the first six months
is 30.4 percent ahead of plan and 6.7
percent ahead of 2022 Revenue before
that Municipal fund transfer as Mr Kane
mentioned
um the 30.4 percent ahead of plan large
number but just remember
or that plan was developed in 2021 at a
time where there was a lot of
uncertainty as we were coming out of
covet so that's why we're so far ahead
um so the 2022 Municipal fund transfer
as I mentioned did not exist in 21 in
fiscal 22 that transfer was just over
100 million dollars 100.1 million and
year to date for 23 we have transferred
66.2 million
factors that affect m r Revenue low
unemployment rates so when people are
working they have the ability to go out
to eat maybe take a vacation stay in
hotels So currently the U.S unemployment
rate is at 3.7 percent New Hampshire is
at 2.6 percent for November compared to
4.2 percent nationally last year and 3.3
percent for New Hampshire last year so
we've seen even more declines in the
unemployment rate which is good for m r
strong wages are also good for m r more
disposable income more ability as I said
to go out to eat take vacations
um weather
we like Sunny Summers we want colorful
foliage snow
a little bit more that would be great
um that tends to drive our m r revenues
we have seen record-breaking tourism in
the last few years both in the fall and
in the Summers hopefully the weather
will maybe take a change this winter so
that tourism obviously helps our our m r
revenues
and then consumer Behavior post pandemic
um
there's more outdoor dining options
expanded takeout options
um consumers have kind of shifted from
maybe more mainstream hotels to the
ability to maybe rent a camp a cottage
or or a home or a condo for their
vacations these are all positive changes
to our m r tax base and I really think
that we've kind of seen what is a new
normal for m r
um maybe if nothing else covid taught us
that we really like to eat out and when
we couldn't do that for a period of time
I think that may have driven
post-pandemic demand people now really
enjoy the ability to eat out or at least
get takeout and I don't think we all
knew how much we liked it until we
couldn't do it
um rental activity rental agents I'm
just talking about a few different areas
of m r rental agents are up 20 over
November of last year full service
hotels are up 10 from November of last
year full service restaurants are up six
percent fast food is up 12 and a half
percent all from just last year so m r
continues to grow we see increased
demand
um it I think
this is a bit of a new a new normal that
we're seeing
so I will pause briefly for any
representative almie
thank you uh could you tell us where we
we will look at that in the next few
slides
senator
thank you thank you commissioner
um so I just want to be clear we're now
instead of dumping all the m r into the
general fund now we're pulling out our
Municipal share portion so it's not
counted as general fund necessarily
Revenue anymore it's now has a special
dedicated fund that based on my math
somewhere between 11 and 12 million
dollars a month we take out of MNR
receipts and dump into this set aside
fund that's correct so last year in
total was 100.1 million that went into
the municipal transfer fund
um this year it'll probably be a little
bit more than that the math is based on
the prior year revenues when we get into
more detailed Revenue estimating we can
walk the Committees through the specific
calculation but thank you yeah comparing
year to year we can at this point really
compare you can compare 23 to 22 because
both years had the transfer but again
the transfer varies year to year so it's
probably helpful to just look at m r on
a gross level and then net out the
transfer thank you Senator Rosenwald
thank you madam chair good morning good
morning
um I've noticed that
um generally the rooms portion is about
17 percent of the total m r revenues but
this year it's something like 24 25.
and you've
well the the restaurants are coming in
kind of just around plan
you mentioned that change in rooms from
hotels to
rental agents and condos is the
department also looking at to what
extent the emergency rental assistance
federal funds that are going into hotels
is driving that portion of the revenues
or will you be able to tell us that
potentially so the m r tax is going to
tax a short-term rental so six months or
less so if any of those rentals are
longer than six months or anticipated to
be longer than six months and they
wouldn't be taxable here but that's
certainly something that we can we can
look into in Greater detail for you
representative ulery has a question
thank you
um
commissioner
you were talking about the the following
up on uh Senator I gotta get the senator
in there now Lang's uh comment regarding
the the 30 that's going back into the
the municipalities
is there some way we could see
with that taken out the comparison of
the meals and rooms going into the
general fund now
minus the 30 so we can see
whether or not we're losing there's as
less Revenue going to this
general fund yes you understand why yes
we can when we get into the specific
Revenue estimating with the Committees
we'll show it both ways so you'll see
the gross amount of total m r collected
then we can show you what's going into
the municipal revenue or Municipal
transfer fund then also show you the net
so you can see
what it would look like if that transfer
wasn't happening and then see what it is
with the transfer
follow-up
can you give us a rough idea now is
there a increased decrease level
m r is growing so in general so
um
yeah that's wonderful news yeah Senator
Lane
just one more thing for committee
members if you get the notice I do I
started on the 15th every month you get
the revenue notices that come out just
remember that 11 million dollars is
going to drop out of that total when
you're reporting it to somebody so if it
says we have 207 million dollars
remember to subtract 11 million dollars
because that's actually going to be the
Surplus that's a great point so when we
report revenues during the month as
Senator Lang said starting on the 15th
you will see the revenue before the
transfer and so we will look very much
ahead of plan because that transfer
hasn't come out yet there is a footnote
in the bottom that will tell you what
the transfer it the specific amount for
that month but yes so it always looks
like on the 15th 16th 17th of the month
18th 19th we're looking great and we're
still usually end up ahead of plan but
we look grossly ahead of Plan before
that transfer comes up that's a great
representative elberger
thank you madam chair
um I'm finding myself a little bit
confused about something on page three
the second bullet point it says the
transfer was 14.6 million per year in FY
right so in in fiscal 2012 we
transferred 14.6 million to the school
building a Debt Service in fiscal 22 we
the transfer was only 8.1 million
and then I assume and 7 million and 23.
I assume that 7 million is year to date
that would be for the total year so The
Debt Service amounts were set back
um when the bonds were issued so that is
7.1 7 million is the total amount that
would be transferred in 23. thank you
thank you madam chair uh quick follow-up
from Senator Lang and then uh
representative rochewart next
so just just on that that building Aid
transfer if I did my math right from my
education committee side we have about
151 million dollars left in bonds that
go out to 2041.
um to to lay off that's broken down into
two pieces one's a municipal payment
that is about a hundred and
seven million dollars and that is a 43
43 million dollar
um back in 2010-11 we bonded operating
expenses we have about 43 million
dollars left of that bond to pay off as
well
representative
thank you madam chair
um looking at the factors that affect
the future meals and room tax revenue
it's kind of a two-part question so how
effective is the state in collecting
meals and rooms from short-term rentals
the airbnbs the vrbos those groups yep
the those um you can see a list of all m
r licensees on our website all m r
operators the two that you mentioned are
license operators and so they will
collect on behalf of the host and remit
to the state okay and then a follow-up
to that or along the same questions I
know there's a lot of discussion at
least in my part of the state about
restricting short-term rentals and um
and and and putting more regulations on
that does that factor into future meals
and room tax revenue if there are less
ability to rent out homes and second
homes for for that sure so
if a consumer wants to rent out a second
home and that's not available because of
short-term rental restrictions they
would really have one or two options
right you can go to a hotel
um or you cannot come at all so if the
result is that fewer people rent any
sort of taxable accommodation then we
would see it an impact to m r If instead
that is just a shift to a different type
of taxable accommodation from a
short-term rental to a full-service
Hotel then the impact on Revenue would
be minimal thank you sure let's go ahead
and move on one more behind you
so that's a great question
um and I don't I'm gonna face this way
okay
um so meals and rentals operators remit
to the state on a monthly basis
um they can remit on a Consolidated
basis so if I am a restaurant owner and
I have a restaurant in Plymouth Concord
and Manchester I can file a Consolidated
return and report all of my revenues on
one return and they're not required to
break out the revenue that's received by
each location so for that to answer that
question it can be it's difficult almost
impossible for us to know
um how much m r revenue is generated in
each specific municipality
also if we were able to do that if
operators were required um it would be
additional work and Reporting on the
part of the operator but if they were
required to break down their m r by
municipality in theory we could report
um by municipality except when you have
the potential for municipalities that
have very few operators so if you have a
small town that has two restaurants the
dra based on our internal policies would
not be able to disclose that information
because if I'm the owner of one
restaurant and I know there's only two
in the town and dra told me there was a
hundred dollars of Revenue and I know
that I was 25 then I know that my
competitor had 75 percent of that so we
get into a little bit of a disclosure
issue but really the the first kind of
Hiccup is the ability for operators to
file Consolidated returns would you be
okay with a quick follow-up question on
that yeah
I could say I wasn't clear how do you
know how much of a check to send to one
Town versus the next versus the next oh
for the distribution so that
distribution is done based on population
thank you let's go ahead and move on
again all of my ways and means members
we're going to be seeing the
commissioner again very soon and we're
going to drill down on this again thank
you
okay so moving on to slide four we'll
just talk a little bit more about m r
um factors additional factors that can
impact m r revenue is obviously consumer
Behavior as we've mentioned any sort of
supply chain constraints that may impact
a restaurant's ability to offer
um either services in general or offer
specific types of food if you know we
saw some of that I think during covid
most of that has resolved but if there's
any supply chain impacts obviously
inflation is something that we're
watching in terms of
m r tax revenue whether fuel prices and
food costs will require restaurants to
raise their prices that could have a
positive impact on m r Revenue because
the m r is collected based on the amount
that the consumer pays so as prices go
up m r Revenue could go up as well
um economic uncertainty again if we get
to a point where folks feel uncertain
about their position in the economy and
they choose to not go out to eat or not
take those vacations we would see an
impact to m r
um as I mentioned uh previously just the
shift in consumer spending from
pre-pandemic to current spending pattern
may continue into the long term as I
mentioned when we all realized how much
we like to eat out when we couldn't do
it for a period of time that seems to be
a little bit of a permanent change to
are you open to a question on that
representative almi
thank you you don't have Labor Force
sure
for restaurants and hotels including the
one I'm in at the moment uh it's pretty
drastic that is a great Point um I think
we've all seen restaurants that either
can't open for the full you know
offering lunch and dinner every day of
the week
those constraints as well that's a great
Point representative thank you
on Slide Five this shows the 10-year
trend
in m r Revenue you see generally we had
seen an increase year over year in
revenue from 2013 to 2019. you'll see
that dip in 2020 a recovery in 2021 and
then as we talked about it looks like
there's a dip in fiscal year 22 but this
is reporting general fund Revenue so
this is after the municipal
fund transfer so fiscal 2021 revenues of
334.7 the transfer did not exist fiscal
22 at 307.2 that is net of the 100.1
million dollar transfer so gross m r in
fiscal 22 was 407.3 so we have seen an
um again as we mentioned earlier you'll
see we are significantly exceeding plan
but plan was developed during a lot of
uncertainty during covid
Senator Lang uh commissioner so if I
look at 19 I'm sorry yeah 19 and 22 to
make them equalize I have to add about
107 million dollars back in giving us a
revenue of about uh 414 million and that
would be equal to what we look at in 19
so we're ahead of we're about 50 million
dollars in gross revenue ahead but after
the adjustment correct thank you correct
Senator Innis
a real quick question
um we've seen a lot of inflation in
restaurant prices hotel rates have gone
up significantly how much of this
increase is due to inflation as opposed
to a real increase in business and when
that of inflation subsides as we hope
um what will be the impacts on on this
Revenue what I'm trying to say is maybe
we shouldn't get quite so excited as we
are
so
I think the the inflation
increasing revenues
you also need to factor in if that
inflation and increased prices has
impacted consumer demand
and so that's kind of the balance that
we maybe don't have the best insight
into because we're just reporting the
revenue but if food prices are
increasing so m r is increasing and the
demand is still there and consumers are
still spending but then we see those
prices go back down you could
potentially see a hit so yeah it's it's
kind of the balance of the Demand versus
the prices
thank you you're welcome
representative Army
thank you and we have a excellent on
marketing program in economic Affairs on
which
changes who it's going after depending
on whether there's a lot of money
washing around in New England or or
isn't at the time and would that be do
you know well maybe we can find out from
them on where they've been spending
their money in the last year yes this
program actually until we started
hitting major bumps was giving us five
percent more a year for years
I believe commissioner Caswell is coming
up right after me and I'm sure he'll be
happy to talk about it he and I had a
brief conversation last week about some
of the um targeted marketing that they
do when they do it why they do it and
how quickly they can shift it if need be
it was actually pretty fascinating so
hopefully he'll cover that with you as
well
on slide six
um this gets to what Senator Rosenwald
brought up earlier I don't have fiscal
23 year to date on here
um but this will just show you kind of
the breakdown between meals rentals and
Motor Vehicles as the components of m r
so meals is the largest portion of our m
r Revenue
the breakdown is fairly consistent I
would just note fiscal 21 you saw a
little bit of a shift towards the meals
with meals being just 80 or going up to
82.1 percent where it had been hovering
around 80 almost consistently in Prior
years and then in 22 was kind of a
precursor to what Senator Rosenwald
mentioned where we've kind of now seen
that shift into rooms rooms is up to 18
percent in fiscal 22 where it had been
15 16 17 previously and I think when we
look at 23 numbers as Senator Rosenwald
mentioned you'll see that shift even
more so we just kind of look to see
um the breakdown so that we can follow
the trends of what's happening in the
representative Ellery
thank you commissioner when we get into
the drill down I've noticed that the uh
81 to 79.7 uh
percentra on the the meals can we have
well will you be able to provide our
relative uh meals and rooms tax
comparison to the other states and
some commentary as to why that's down at
79 instead of back up at 80 as I have a
suspicion but I just would love to know
sure we can look at the rates in other
states we also can look at a breakdown a
more detailed breakdown as I mentioned
in previous slides about what makes up
meals so whether it's fast food for
instance right during covid we saw a
significant increase in fast food a
decrease in full service restaurants
right McDonald's was open but maybe
Applebee's was closed so we can give you
a more detailed breakdown of the
components within each of these as well
appreciate it thank you thank you madam
chair thank you representative
Southworth thank you madam chair
um yeah as a follow-up to Jordan's
question I'm interested in this data um
about the pieces that are really kind of
the large discrepancy in New Hampshire
where you have businesses closing new
businesses opening up some are just
barely getting by
um you know all those things we kind of
hear about the middle in all these
presentations but as many people know
New Hampshire has a huge range I mean
I'm from the Seacoast business is
booming but that's not true in other
parts of the state
we can we have a breakdown of m r
Revenue also by County so we can show it
to you by county and the changes over
time we can also give you data on the
number of licenses that have closed as
opposed to new licenses that have opened
again we can do that by County so we
that's a great point we can get into
okay
next up the real estate transfer tax on
the real estate transfer tax is imposed
on the sale transfer or granting of real
property at a rate of a dollar fifty per
hundred dollars of the price or
consideration of the transfer half is
paid by the seller half is paid by the
buyer
Rhett has increased in recent years we
saw 3.7 percent increase in 2020 over
2019 a 32.4 percent increase in 21 over
20. a 10 10.9 percent increase in 22
over 21.
for fiscal 23 actual revenue for the
first six months is 26.3 percent ahead
of plan and 5.4 percent ahead of Prior
year
this is I think what we've all seen in a
bit of a real estate boom here in New
Hampshire maybe possibly driven by covid
and folks wanting to move to New
Hampshire move out of more urban areas
um
things that we are watching at this
point are the interest rates obviously
as those go up that makes potential
buyers more difficult for buyers to buy
or might dissuade buyers from buying in
the first place mortgage rates increased
from just over three percent in October
of 21 to 6.9 percent in October of 22.
so Rising interest rates are something
that we're watching inflation as that
maybe pinches some household budgets
that may impact whether or not folks are
able to purchase or move to a new home
the slowing of demand obviously driven
as I mentioned by the interest rates by
inflation
the other thing that that I think is
worth noting with respect to the real
estate transfer tax is property values
so uh property values were
214.1 billion that's the total equalized
value for all property in New Hampshire
for April of 2022 versus 193.5 billion
in April of 21. so 22 saw a 10 increase
in total equalized value in New
Hampshire over 21 the previous years we
were looking at a five percent
year-over-year increase so we have seen
significant increase in the value of
property
factors that can affect the future
um red Revenue
the housing market Trend home prices may
have peaked we're not sure I don't know
um if they have peaked
um that could impact Revenue decline in
the demand again from the interest rates
from the higher prices and just the low
inventory that we've seen for a number
of years now
with Rhett the thing to remember is that
it's a balance between the number of
sales the sales volume and the prices
so sales can fall as we've seen at times
but if prices go up that can sustain the
rent Revenue
the opposite is also true if the number
of sales increases but the prices go
down again the rent Revenue can be
sustained it's really when we start to
see the volume go down and the prices go
um we continue to watch the economy low
unemployment rate strong wages generally
that is good for the housing market the
inflation rate rise in prices Energy
prices Energy prices especially this
time of year that's something that a
home buyer is likely to take into
account when deciding whether or not to
purchase a home
and then just general economic
uncertainty if buyers are uncertain
about the economic future that may
dissuade them from purchasing
future outlook changes in interest rates
will they continue to climb how long
will they climb how high will they go
and the tapering buyer demand so average
days on the market increased 7.7 percent
in November of 22 as compared to
November of 21 and pending sales
decreased in 22 as compared to 21. so it
the market is cooling it's not that same
as soon as it's listed it's sold for 10
above asking it's starting to to come
down a bit
year-over-year change for November 22.
new property listings and pending sales
decreased for single-family homes and
condos
for November 22 the sales price and
monthly supply of inventory increased so
again we're seeing the volume decline
the the price increase
along with the inventory so the homes
are staying on the market a little bit
longer but the prices are still
increasing
November 22 single family home had a
20-year low for the affordability index
so the housing affordability index
measures whether a typical family earns
enough to qualify for a mortgage loan so
an index of 120 would mean that median
household income is a hundred and twenty
percent of what they would need to
qualify under the prevailing interest
rates so any any affordability index
over a hundred means that median income
would qualify you for purchasing a home
November 22 is currently at 69 so median
family income is not enough
to Quality about 30 short to qualify for
um purchasing a home at the prevailing
interest rates
it means that homes are getting harder
to afford therefore the sales volume is
on page 10 this is the 10-year Revenue
you will note that the 22 plan is on the
green line which was
197.8 in fiscal 22 Revenue was 232.6 so
we exceeded plan and the 23 plan is in
the red line which is
181.9 which is less than the 22 plan so
we anticipated that the increase in ret
that we had seen as a result of covet
and during covid was going to start to
decline it hasn't happened yet so you'll
see the revenues
um our exceeding plan and still exceed
prior year but I think it's coming
the the housing market signs are
indicating that it is slowing so we
might start to see either ret level off
or maybe start to see a bit of a decline
but we can talk about that in Greater
detail when we get into the actual
Revenue estimates and we will have some
some presentations from realtors in the
both the residential and Commercial
world coming tomorrow so representative
Petrie has a question and then Senator
Murphy please
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question do you have a
breakdown of property values by county
we do we would break down a property
values by county and also by town and
that's available on our website but I
can get a um a link to the chair to
thank you madam chair one quick question
this housing affordability index is that
a New Hampshire specific number that is
all right thank you
Senator Lane so sticking with that
question that line the the affordable
index is really a price and interest
rate as compared to wage is that is that
the breakdown of that and as your price
goes up and the interest goes up your if
your wage doesn't go up in the same
matter then you're more likely to not be
able to get an affordable home correct
next we have the tobacco tax
so the tobacco tax is
um on levied on each pack of cigarettes
at a dollar 78 per pack of 20 and 2.23
cents per pack of 25 that
um is indicated by a stamp that goes on
the bottom of every pack of cigarettes
that's sold
the tobacco tax is also levied on all
other tobacco products at a later rate
of 65.03 percent of the wholesale sales
price so that would be your loose
tobacco other products like that
stamp sales
um
and OTP make up the total tobacco tax so
we tend to report in the revenue Focus
Etc on the total tobacco tax but we'll
give you a bit of a breakdown here again
so you can see the different components
I would note and I'll go into detail in
a later slide that other tobacco
products also includes the taxation of
e-cigarettes and we'll talk about those
are taxed a little bit differently and
we'll talk about that in a couple slides
so tobacco tax revenue over the last
three years we saw a 5.7 percent
increase in 2020 over the prior year an
18.1 percent increase in 21 over 20
then we saw an 8.2 percent decrease in
22 from 21. year to date we are seven
percent below plan and 4.7 percent below
prior year
the share of OTP continues to grow so if
you think of it like a pie chart the
largest portion of Revenue is stamp
sales but the portion that is other
tobacco products is growing so it
currently makes up 13.2 percent of the
tobacco tax compared to in fiscal 2012
it was 3.4 percent so again we're seeing
a little bit of a shift to other tobacco
products and away from the traditional
cigarettes and stamp sales
factors that contribute to our tobacco
tax revenue cross-border elasticity it
is estimated that 52.4 percent of
cigarettes sold in New Hampshire are
consumed outside of New Hampshire
so we have a very low tax rate compared
to our surrounding states so we see a
lot of our cigarettes
go to other states
it's important to note I think if you
actually look at the number of of stamps
that we sell and you look at our
population
it would probably be very jarring if if
we were to actually consume all of those
cigarettes here we'd probably have some
severe Public Health crises
um so it's just know that about half of
our cigarettes that are sold are
consumed outside of State
obviously public sentiment on Tobacco
consumption
um we tend to see a little bit of a dip
in in tobacco tax stamp sales in the
beginning of the year maybe as there's
some New Year's resolutions to quit
smoking
um so you know January February tend to
be lower months in revenue for us so as
as public sentiment changes relative to
tobacco that can impact the tobacco tax
availity of Menthol and flavored tobacco
products that are banned in
Massachusetts so since June of 2020
um Massachusetts has banned all flavored
tobacco products including menthol
cigarettes that has driven a lot of
demand to New Hampshire especially at
our border towns
the initial impact was estimated to be a
22 percent increase in New Hampshire so
again we already had the lower tax rate
we had that cross-border elasticity and
then there were products that were no
longer available in Massachusetts that
people came to New Hampshire to purchase
there is also a potential Federal ban on
Menthol flavored cigarettes and all
flavors and cigars that would prohibit
New Hampshire as well from selling those
products
the soonest that that would go into
effect would be roughly a year from now
the impact on our revenues would really
depend on if consumers that are
purchasing menthol cigarettes and
flavored cigars whether they would shift
to a different product a non-menthilated
product or a non-flavored cigar or
whether they would stop consuming
altogether so it's really the consumer
behavior that would ultimately Drive the
impact on revenues this is something
that we're watching
um and we can you know talk to the
Committees
as you get into Revenue estimating about
what we think in terms of the likelihood
what would happen if this Federal ban
went into effect
commission representative question
I thank you again commissioner I just
saw that we're perfectly clear New
Hampshire does not uh discriminate
between uh flavored and non-flavored on
our tax rate so there's no way we would
know what the impact would be
though the only way we would know would
be to talk to our wholesalers
um they're the so the wholesalers
purchase the tobacco tax stamps from us
they sell to the retailers and then the
retailers sell to the consumers
um we have a good working relationship
with the wholesalers so we can get some
estimates on how much menthol cigarettes
they sell compared to non-methylated
um but again it would really it's an
estimate in terms of what the impact
would be and that to your point thing we
do here is a guest thank you and to your
point the tax rate is not different so
there's not an easy way to do that thank
you representative almi
thank you and it's quite a difference
between 20 and
on 21
21-22 and
we've got just as I recall we have one
major distributor and a couple of
somewhat smaller ones on and one of the
answers to that would be if they had
decided as they sometimes have done in
order to send a signal to us or someone
else that they were going to not get
bonds for the months before the end of
the year and get them after that on I
don't know that's half of the question
the other one is on
can you find out
what Massachusetts thinks is going on
with their Menthol customers
that is are they quitting because it's
too much trouble to come up here and
acquire their cigarettes or uh perhaps
going to eat vaping or something or
what's going on sure so to answer your
first question yes we track the amount
of bond receivable we have in any given
month and we can go over that in Greater
detail when we come before the committee
in terms of what's happening in
Massachusetts there's actually a tax
Foundation study that was done which is
where I got some of my numbers that
showed um that New Hampshire had that
roughly 20 to 22 percent increase in
stamp sales and Rhode Island did as well
so there was a a move of consumers
um when they couldn't buy their
mentholated products in Massachusetts
anymore they kind of went to the two
closest states to do so there's probably
also a shift
um to e-cigarettes
um and and we're actually gonna I'm
gonna talk about that in a greater
detail in the next couple of slides so
we can we can look at what's been going
on with respect to e-cigarettes
thank you thank you just remind the
members we have there's what 30 pages 32
pages in this slide presentation we have
about 40 minutes left because you want
to take a break after this presentation
before the next one so the commission is
going to be in front of both the Senate
and the house ways and convenience
committee a lot you'll get her nowhere
on a first name basis so there'd be
page 12.
I mentioned taxation of e-cigarettes so
the e-cigarette tax went into effect on
January 1st of 2020 in New Hampshire it
is levied on both closed systems which
is when you purchase
or so they tell me
um a single piece an e-cigarette that's
one piece
um and also on open systems which is
where you have an interchangeable or
refillable liquid the closed systems and
open systems are taxed differently so
the closed system rate is 30 cents per
milliliter on the volume of the liquid
or other substance that's containing
nicotine in the cartridge and then on an
open system it's eight percent of the
wholesale sales price
so this is different than the 65.03
percent OTP tax rate E-cigarettes are
taxed um differently from that
the chart on this page really all it's
showing is from the Inception of the
taxation
um just the increase that we've seen
um so you'll see that in July of fiscal
21 we were
collecting just over 300 000 in tobacco
tax revenue from e-cigarettes on a
monthly basis now coming into fiscal 23
we had a high in July of 843 843
000 and we're just
um about 760
000 in December so we've seen a
significant increase in Revenue due to
this slide is just showing the 10-year
trend on page 13 as we've seen from
other taxes
I just point out if you look from fiscal
16 to fiscal 19 you'll see a consistent
downward Trend this is something that
representative Ami and I have talked
about numerous times in ways and means
we were seeing a roughly three percent
decrease in tobacco tax revenue year
over year it felt like we knew what was
happening we knew what was going on then
covid hit Massachusetts banned certain
products and from 19 to 21 we saw an
increase in tobacco tax revenue
21 to 22 you will see that decrease this
might be more of the normalizing
um you know not only the Massachusetts
ban of certain products but I think also
covid it being a stressful time there
was a lot of uncertainty it was probably
not the time that a lot of folks
um decided to quit smoking
um it the the other external factors at
the time may have driven some demand so
we may be seeing some normalizing
year-to-date numbers compared to Prior
year seem to indicate the same thing so
we may start looking at that more three
to four percent year-over-year decrease
foreign
page 14 this is showing you just tobacco
tax stamp Revenue so this is just the
the tax on the packages of cigarettes
you'll see again that downward Trends 16
17 18 was relatively flat 19 decrease
but then the increase in 21 20 and 21.
most likely due again to covid and the
Menthol ban in Massachusetts
and then on page 15 this is just showing
you other tobacco product stamp other
tobacco tax revenue
the blue is your traditional
OTP Revenue at 65.03 of the wholesale
sales price the orange portion is when
we added e-cigarettes so orange is just
showing you the portion of OTP Revenue
related to e-cigarettes and again you
can see that that has been growing
next up we have the interest in
dividends tax
IND is assessed on interest and dividend
income of individuals Partnerships and
fiduciaries the tax rate was five per
five percent for taxable periods ending
on or before December 31st of 2022 and
is in the process of being phased out
so the rate will be four percent for
taxable periods ending on or after
December 31st of 2023 the calendar year
that we are currently in we will go to
three percent then two percent then one
percent and then the tax will be fully
repealed for periods beginning after
IND Revenue over the past few years has
fluctuated a little bit we've seen an
increase of just under 10 percent from
19 to 20. we saw a four percent decrease
from 20 to 21 but then saw a 30 percent
increase from 21 to 22.
actual revenue for the first six months
is 1.8 percent above plan we're actually
pretty close to plan so
um that's performing well and 5.4
percent above last year
factors that can impact IND economy and
stock market performance obviously
changing makeup of how
um IND is paid over time for example
distributions we'll talk about this in a
later slide you hear interest in
dividends and so interest and dividends
are the first things that come to mind
in terms of the tax base but we also tax
distributions and so as those components
the mix of those components changes over
time that can impact the tax
how much money you have in the bank and
interest rates also impacting IND as
interest rates go up that would indicate
that we would receive additional IND
Revenue
tenure Trend
um
fairly consistent increase in revenue
from 2016 to 2020 that slight dip in 21
and then increased Revenue again in 22.
you will see that the 22 and 23 plans
are very close to one another we
expected that Revenue might kind of be
um have limited growth from 22 to 23
also included in that is the impact of
this shows you the breakdown of the
at the bottom is probably the easiest
way to see it in the chart you'll see
the percent of IND that is from
distributions from dividends from
federal tax exempt income and then from
interest
if you look at tax year 21 you'll see
that distributions were 48.2 percent
made up 48.2 percent of the IND Revenue
that we received that is a significant
increase from the 17.9 percent in 2012.
so that's really a sign of of a strong
economy strong profits that are being
distributed
um and then therefore taxed
you will also notice the interest
portion in 2012 was 35.9 percent in tax
year 21 it was 9 so again lower interest
rates
um making up a smaller component of the
IND tax as a whole we may see and I
expect that we will see this interest
portion increase as interest rates
increase
all right I guess we have a number of
backed up questions here so we'll start
representative Platt and go to Senator
uh
yes thank you that chart has no Legend
what color means what I noticed that as
I was talking
that's why I referred you to the chart
we will add a legend to that I
believe
the distributions are blue
the Dividends are orange
the federal tax exempt interest is gray
Senator Roswell thank you madam chair
to to what extent does that department
have information
on large family trusts where the IND
liability is transferred to an
individual's tax return versus just like
a family who pays IND tax do we know
anything about
these trusts that we've enabled
we can look into that I mean all that
we're going to know is what's reported
to us so if it
if it's not taxable it's not going to
show up on anything that we receive
so there has been you know changes in in
recent years to the trust Statute in New
Hampshire and so we can we can try to do
a bit of analysis looking back over time
but we're only going to have information
of what's reported to us on a tax return
thank you
as a representative I'm poorovich how do
to be you know strength of the economy
and how much it's been to the Federal
you know policy of keeping interest
rates are deficient involved which
decreases the interest anybody can get
there is no income to tax because there
is no interest in received while you
know the same policy about a large
institution because the property came up
by the you know
excessively low interest rate so correct
that's a great point and something that
we can do when we come before the
Committees is not only give you the
percentages but give you the dollar
amounts so you can see whether you know
to your point
um it may be fairly consistent interest
amounts but it's looking like a smaller
proportion because of the total Pi so
the percentages can be a little bit
potentially misleading so we can give
actual dollar figures for the totals
which might be easier to um to see
what's going on there
thank you representative almi
thank you on I was asking this question
yesterday actually but on we just
started hearing about distributions a
couple of years ago I guess I see why
now but can you explain the difference
between distributions that is in the tax
law between distributions and uh
dividends
when we come before Ways and Means next
we're going to give you a more detailed
primer on each of the taxes and how they
operate so we can get into that detail
at that point and that'll hopefully
serve as a bit of a reference for you
going forward
thank you could I just have a very short
follow-up on are the distributions
something that only uh stockholders
get
not necessarily okay I don't believe so
representative
thank you madam chair I'm wondering if
uh when I look at the distributions
increasing so dramatically I'm wondering
if there's a real estate sales component
to that because if you've got companies
that are handling real estate selling
real estate buying and and flipping
might that distribution
potentially by that potentially and
that's why too I think it would be
helpful to see the actual numbers as
opposed to just the percentages and I
wish I had thought of that before right
now
um so that you can see you know
distributions that has increased as a
percentage of total IND
over time but it'd be helpful to see the
actual dollar increase as well because
this might be a little bit inflated
okay please continue
utility property tax so we have a couple
smaller taxes that I'm going to cover
and I'll try to go through these quickly
and then we'll talk about business taxes
you'll notice I saved that for the end
um so the utility property tax is
imposed on the value of utility property
at a rate of 6.60 cents per one thousand
dollars of value and the dra determines
those values as of the April 1st of each
year
audited upt Revenue over the past few
years we saw 9.6 percent increase year
over year and 20 and 11.8 percent
decrease in twenty one thirteen point
four percent increase in twenty two year
to date we are 3.5 percent ahead of plan
and nine point nine percent ahead of
Prior year
tax year 22 assessments were 43.6
million dollars that's based on a
utility property value of 6.6 billion
factors that it can impact upt obviously
the development of new uh renewable
energy facilities that's more taxable
property the valuation of the property
directly drives the taxes that we
collect and then Energy prices supply
and demand that can impact obviously the
profits of the utilities and then the
profits contribute to the value that we
assess them at so these are are all
things that kind of contribute to the
utility property tax I did not include a
graph or any chart for this one it's
roughly between 40 and 45 million
dollars a year it's pretty
straightforward
communication Services tax
sorry sorry while we're there
representative allery please
thank you madam chair thank you
commissioner again sorry no worries uh
the the question is
this 6.6 per thousand
and we recently had the upgrades that
took place throughout the southern part
of the state with you know screwed up
traffic and everything else uh
what effect or is there a methods that
you're often methodology by which your
office could determine what effect that
had on the overall cost if any
of providing electricity to consumers in
the state we wouldn't have any
information about the cost to the
consumers we would just be looking at
any impacts to the value of the utility
okay thank you I just want I wonder how
we can get that information would be
very interesting to know
thank you sure you're welcome
communication Services tax seven percent
on all two-way Communications
in 2012 an exclusion of charges for
internet access decreased CST revenues
significantly we cannot go back on that
change there is a federal prohibition on
taxing internet access New Hampshire was
grandfathered into that provision but
since it has been repealed we can no
longer tax internet access
and you can see you know cstu used to be
between 76 and a half to 81 million
dollars following the removal of the
taxation of internet access it's dropped
um to 47.1 to 59.3 million and then in
the last three years we've considered
continued to see other declines in CST
as well
uh fiscal 22 CST Revenue was just under
30 million for the first six months of
the year we are 23.8 percent below plan
and 6.4 percent below prior year
things that have incred uh impacted the
CST Revenue outside of the taxation of
internet access just a decrease in land
lines as you all know for a long time
people had a landline and a cell phone
maybe a landline and two cell phones now
there's just fewer and fewer landlines
more cell phones so the decrease in
landlines affects CST
modern pricing and purchasing trends for
Wireless Communications
so if you look at your cell phone bill
you will see typically that there is a
portion of your bill that you pay that
is related to your data usage and a
portion that is related to your voice
that data is internet access and is not
taxable
The Voice portion is taxable so as
wireless communication companies have
shifted the portion of your bill away
from voice to data that has a negative
impact on CST Revenue
VoIP and video conferencing that has a
positive impact on CST Revenue
um something that has
um maybe uh uh increased a bit during
covet as we all learned how to use zoom
and other
um video conferencing and VOIP options
um so that is could have a positive
impact to CST Revenue
CST Revenue as you'll see is just about
30 million dollars a year it's a
relatively small Revenue source
New Hampshire has two business taxes we
have the business Enterprise tax and the
business profits tax the bet is assessed
on the sum of all compensation paid or
accrued interest pay to recruit and
dividends paid by the business the BPT
is assessed on income from the conduct
of business activity within the state so
BPT is your traditional business income
tax bet is a tax regardless of whether
your business is profitable
the BPT conforms to the Internal Revenue
code in effect on December 31st of 2018
for taxable periods beginning on or
after 2020 so we are currently conformed
to the code of December 31st of 2018 in
order to change that code there needs to
be legislation we are not what is called
a rolling Conformity state where we just
update the code as it changes we are
static Conformity so we conform to a
specific date and then the legislature
decides to update the date if they so
choose
factors that affect business taxes
obviously the economy
federal tax reform and stimulus programs
mergers and Acquisitions various credits
or exemptions and statutory changes
on page 22 we'll talk about some of
those statutory changes that have
happened in recent years
first market-based sourcing for taxable
periods beginning on or after December
31st of 21 this is Rel this impacts
um a multi-states business apportionment
how they apportion their income for
services that they provide we were what
was called the cost of performance state
where you would look to where the
service
was performed a market-based sourcing
state that we are now we look to where
the customer is
so if I'm an accountant and my customer
is in Massachusetts under a cost of
performance State we would have said
that my activity was here in New
Hampshire
under a market-based sourcing State we
say that my activity is in Massachusetts
because that's where my customer is
so that change was effective for taxable
periods ending on or after December 31st
of 21 we have received and are analyzing
calendar year returns but have not yet
received all fiscal year filers so we'll
have additional information on that when
we come before the Committees thank you
another change cap on credit carryovers
so a business
um from year to year can have a credit
carryover they may make estimate
payments during the year which are in
excess of their liability they have the
opportunity at the end of the year to
either have the excess refunded to them
or to take it as a credit to carry over
to Future periods
for taxable periods ending on or after
December 1st 31st of 22 they cannot
carry forward more than 500 percent of
their taxable liability
that amount decreases to 250 percent for
December 31st of 25 and a hundred
percent for December 31st of 27. what
this means is that we could see
increased refunds
um out of the business taxes and that
would start to happen with that 500 cap
that would be for returns for calendar
year filers that we start receiving in
March and April so we have a taxpayer
has more than 500 percent
um in their liability in a CCO we will
need to refund whatever is in excess of
500 so that's something that we'll be
watching closely as returns start to
um another change single sales Factor
apportionment that is a change for
taxable periods on ending on or after
December 31st of 22.
prior to
um taxable periods ending out or after
December 31st of 22 again this is an
apportionment issue for taxpayers that
operate in multiple States
if you operate in multiple States
historically we would apportion your
profits to New Hampshire based on
your payroll your property and your
sales
for December 31st 22 forward we're only
going to a portion based on your sales
so if again if you operate in New
Hampshire in Massachusetts we're going
to look at how much of your sales are in
New Hampshire versus how much are in
Massachusetts and that's how we're going
to apportion your income and only tax
your sales into New Hampshire
those returns will start to be filed in
March and April and again will be
something that we will be watching
the next two bullets I won't read in
detail these are just changes to the
filing threshold for bet and BPT there
we're increasing the filing threshold
which means fewer returns will need to
be filed so
um for BPT the filing threshold for
taxable periods beginning January 123
you will not need to file a return
unless your gross business income is in
excess of a hundred and three thousand
dollars we will continue to adjust that
amount biennily going forward based on
CPI and for bet the filing thresholds
for taxable periods beginning January
123 will be 281 000 in Gross business
receipts or 281 000 of your Enterprise
Value tax base so again the goal here is
just to reduce the number of returns
that need to be filed with us it's
better for small businesses reduces the
amount of work that's necessary at the
dra and again the thresholds will
continue to adjust every other year
two last statutory changes to cover
first net operating loss calculation
will be apportioned only in the year of
the loss for taxable periods beginning
on or after December 31st 22
historically the nol would be
apportioned in the year of the loss and
in the year that the nol was utilized so
it was apportioned twice now with this
single apportionment
um they'll essentially will be more nol
available to businesses so we will see a
decrease in Revenue as a result of this
change
and then BBT
um rate reduces from 7.6 to 7.5 for
taxable periods ending on or after
December 31st of 23. remember this is
only a BPT rate change there was no bet
rate change for this tax period
okay while we're on legislative changes
do we have any quick questions on those
representative Almy
well a lot of these have a great deal of
detail and
purpose behind them and I think we're
going to have to get into them
agreed we can go over these in more
detail in the Committees
um especially the changes to
apportionment apportionment is
complicated
um so we will be available to the
committee as much as necessary to make
sure everyone
feels like they at least have a minor
understanding of of some of the
technical changes that have been made
recently we're happy to do that so I
could just briefly uh in deference to a
representative major who made this his
the last 10 years an obsession on the
cap on the credit carry forward is in
really important this committee did it
but it is really important to maintain
some version of it because we owed I
think uh 400 million it got up over 300
million above 300 million to uh
companies for credit that they kept on
our books and we have not accounted for
that and if they show up and ask for it
back uh we've got a problem so what
we're trying to do is reduce it as much
uh representative excuse me Senator Lang
sorry either one works
um so just sticking with that topic of
credit carryover I'm assuming as we go
forward you'll give us some estimates of
what those refunds might look like in
December 31st of 25 and
27 so we have an idea of that for the
future we um we did a fiscal note at the
time those were changes that I believe
were in House Bill 2 but we can
obviously update them we'll have actuals
once we start receiving the returns so
yes we'll we'll keep you updated on what
we believe that impact to be and in all
reality
um the the impact can kind of happen in
a couple ways if a business is aware of
it they may choose to decrease their
estimated payments and not necessarily
be in a refund position so there's a
combination of potential of foregone
Revenue as opposed to having to issue a
refund and there may be a greater chance
of the decrease in estimated payments
which would be foregone Revenue if we
start to see an economic downturn or
slow down businesses may say hey I'll
keep my money and I'll use what I have
on account so we'll keep an eye on all
that and we'll make sure we update you
Senator Rosenwald has a question thank
you madam chair this is not exactly
related to the business taxes but will
um dra be able to
update both the house and the Senate on
the cost of not taxing the PPP loans and
exactly what fiscal years those costs
the short answer is no oops
um
because
when we produced the fiscal note for
those for um exempting PPP loans from
gross income there was guidance from the
IRS at the time that was instructing
businesses to
um assume that their loan would be
forgiven
and therefore
we anticipated that businesses had paid
in assuming New Hampshire's perspective
and assuming that the loan would be
forgiven what actually ended up
happening is they didn't do that they
waited for the loan to actually be
forgiven and by that point our
legislation had passed
so I think there were you're probably
remembering there are pretty significant
Revenue s impacts for Revenue that like
estimated at the time that really I just
don't think ever came to fruition ah
okay so we're kind of for lack of a
better term out of the woods on that one
okay those changes are behind us not
something that we need to worry about
and I guess fortunately the impact
didn't happen to the extent that we
anticipated thank you sure thank you
madam
okay
this is just a quick overview of
business tax revenues for fiscal 2013 to
um
I would probably just bring your
attention to the middle column the
change in Revenue as a percent
you'll see the decrease of 11.9 percent
in fiscal 20 and then an increase of
41.3 and 22.22 percent
um business taxes can be volatile
they're probably our hardest tax to
estimate
um recent volatility really was kind of
magnified by by covid
um and
the uncertainty of businesses but then
the kind of the strong economy that
seems to have come out of covid
um fiscal year to date we are 28.7
percent ahead of plan and 2.7 percent
ahead of last year so we may be seeing a
little bit of a slowing in the growth of
business taxes
um but we'll talk about the timing of
business taxes in just a couple of
slides so this was really just meant as
a little bit of a history and to show
you that business access can be volatile
factors that contribute to business tax
revenue
um overall businesses continue to show
strong financial performance
I think we all know in general some
businesses or some industries did better
than others during covid I think we're
fortunate here in New Hampshire that we
have a fairly diverse tax base when it
comes to the various industries that
contribute to our business taxes
um certainly there are states that rely
very heavily on tourism or very heavily
on oil we have a diversity of businesses
within the state different Industries
and so I think that kind of helped us
weather the storm of covid a little bit
if if one industry like restaurants were
struggling because they were closed
another industry like retail sales were
doing well we have all of those
Industries here and so we we came out of
covet I think better than than some of
the other states
factors that affect future business tax
revenue we talked about some statutory
changes already we'll cover that in
Greater detail when we're before the
Committees the economy supply chain
constraints obviously continue to be
kind of out there as a looming issue
um the inflation rate and that impact on
consumer spending low unemployment rate
um on one hand is good but as
representative Ami alluded to earlier
with restaurants
um that can be bad if businesses can't
find the staff to staff their businesses
that can also drive up labor costs
future outlook interest rate changes we
talked about
um earlier continued global geopolitical
stability economic uncertainty
these are all things that we're watching
um for what will come I will let the
people that are going to talk after me
talk about what they anticipate to
happen with the economy
um but you know we will watch for some
slowing or halting of growth we will
watch the unemployment rate and then
we'll see what happens generally as the
economy moves forward
this is just a slide of the 10-year
trend on business taxes which I kind of
this slide
um just gives you a breakdown of our
business tax revenue
we receive Revenue in a variety of ways
we receive it on tax notices which is
the teal color we receive it on a return
which is blue
we receive Revenue with extensions which
are green which is where you pay your
tax liability and we give you an
extension for you to give us your full
filled out return
we receive revenue and estimates in red
and then we send out Revenue in refunds
in Orange
what I want to just note here is that
estimates are our largest source of
Revenue
estimates are a half page sheet
it includes the taxpayer's name
identification number and the amount of
money that they're paying
so we have very little information on
the majority of the revenue that we
receive which is why I point out at
various times when we start receiving
returns for certain statutory changes
because we don't know the information
until that return is filed if it is
timely filed it is three or four months
after the end of the taxpayers fiscal
year
if it is on extension you add seven
months to that so we're close to a year
sometimes after the end of the taxpayers
year before we get all the information
that we need to tell you what's actually
happening so we do our best but just
know unless there's a nice little love
note with the estimate that tells me why
they're you know doubled it or why they
Senator link thank you so uh
commissioner so understanding it's not
again we have a lot of freshmen the
estimates are based on the quarterly
that they submit right so they
anticipate the end of the year I guess
I'm gonna have to pay 100 bucks so I'm
gonna pay out 25 every quarter until I
hit my hundred dollars correct but my
liability might be more or less from
that correct and so there's penalties if
you make an underestimate you underpay
your estimates but there's a safe harbor
if you pay an amount that's equal to 90
of your prior year so as long as you're
making estimates based on your prior
year liability your percent essentially
protected from any penalties if your
estimates are not sufficient to cover
your year-end liability so which is why
you will see that obviously we do get
Revenue
that come in on extensions and returns
because that's Revenue that was not
covered through the estimated payments
um but yes in general they estimate
their liability divided by four and send
on page 28
this just very quickly breaks down
Revenue estimate Revenue being our
largest source
um based on the type of entity so
fiduciary's proprietorships Partnerships
and corporations so you'll just see
corporations contribute to the majority
of the revenue that we receive if anyone
is familiar with the triangles that we
kind of produce in our annual report
this is not news to you but the majority
of our Revenue comes from corporations
in particular from your large
multinational corporations that file
what's called an 1120 we or Water's Edge
return
page 29 just is showing a breakdown
between BPT and bet everything that I've
covered up to this point has generally
been the two taxes together
I think this is helpful to see though
um that historically Benton BPT have
kind of tracked very similarly in recent
Years you'll see a pretty significant
difference in the slope of the lines for
bet and BPT so really this is just a
result of profits profits are just
growing at a higher rate in recent years
I think as we all understand then the
and then on page 30 just I think helpful
to kind of see all of the taxes together
so you can see
um how the taxes have generally
performed during covid
um our taxes were generally flat or
positive for most of the taxes so as I
said previously we fared covet pretty
well but at the bottom it just kind of
gives you an idea you know our business
taxes are 1.2 billion and then going
down to CST at 30 million so just to
give you some kind of perspective on
which taxes are the largest that we
collect
on page 31 Mr Kane alluded to this but
what we've included here is
um
our fiscal 23 tax revenues so you can
see what we collected in the first six
months
versus what the first six months plan
was so for business taxes you'll see
we're 28.7 percent ahead
I really want to draw your attention to
the last six months
plan as a percent of total plan so
you'll see for business taxes utility
property tax and Communication Service
tax we've collected roughly half of the
revenue it's
pretty evenly spread throughout the year
business taxes are shifted a little bit
more toward the second half of the year
with March and April returns estimates
and then June estimates
you'll see for meals and rentals tobacco
when the real estate transfer tax that
we've likely already collected a little
more than half of the revenue and that's
really due to some slowing in the winter
months we talked about people maybe
quitting smoking in the early part of
the calendar year
um real estate transactions tend to be
slower in winter months m r we can you
know it's usually the summer and the
fall that produce a little bit more of
the revenue
the real Focus though for IND you'll see
we're going to receive over 75 percent
of the revenue in the second half of the
year that is through estimates that are
due January 15th
returns in April and then another round
of estimates in June so there's a ways
to go with IND Revenue so I just put
that out there in terms of timing
um it I wouldn't especially with IND I
wouldn't draw too many conclusions based
on where we are for the first half of
the year just because there's so much
revenue still to come in
and then the very last slide just to be
thorough
there are some other taxes that dra
administers that we didn't cover today
the Medicaid enhancement tax the next
thing to note about Medicaid enhancement
tax is we have non-binding estimates
that are due January 15th we'll report
to the Committees based on what we
receive of those non-binding estimates
we also administer the nursing facility
quality assessment the railroad tax and
private car the excavation tax and
Timber tax also known as sticks and
stones
and the Statewide education property tax
so just to dot all of our eyes and cross
all of our T's I want it to be thorough
and list them all out
wonderful thank you very much that was a
great overview we will learn more you
will learn more do we have any final
questions between before we take a short
break
great thank you again thank you could
you please maybe plan on January 23rd to
come back that's just for house ways and
needs okay okay thank you we'll take a
break until 11 and then we will meet
foreign
good morning
again
Welcome to our state treasurer
Monica mezapelli I hope I'm getting that
right you you got it right thank you
excellent uh our Treasurer was elected
during the joint session of the newly
allowed elected legislature uh just
recently to a second two-year term and
she uh joined the state treasury in 2014
serving as Deputy treasurer for nearly
six years before being appointed
commissioner and she had she's worked in
the legislative budget office as well
she was in the audit division since the
year 2000. she is a certified public
accountant and holds the American
Institute of certified public
accountants designation of Chartered
Global Management accountant so we
welcome you here today thank you for
being here
thank you madam chair and thank you good
morning members of the committee it is a
pleasure to be here this morning with
all of you there's a lot to talk about
but I know we're going to focus on three
so I will start with
um
I will start what we covered last year
last year we were
um we were talking about uh how we were
recovering from the economic crisis that
occurred during the pandemic we had an
extraordinary recovery revenues helped
performed
and we also were hearing about supply
chain disruption the imbalance of
Workforce so all of those things were
happening last year when we when I was
with you before and and so 2002 was
another Rocky year right we we um it was
the year of inflation it was
um we continue to hear about Workforce
and and and again inflation it was it is
a global phenomenon so
um what happened in 2002 is all the
central banks around the world it
started increasing rates so that really
was what caused a lot of disruption in
2020 to so we had a stock market that
didn't like that who had the worst
performance since 2008 since the Great
Recession the bond market had the worst
performance in history so they did not
like to see that high inflation in
seeing how the central banks were trying
to combat
that you know that new condition and
economy so so with that I will start
with just you know discussing what we
will cover today and again we're going
to talk about the state's Financial
condition
talk a little bit about our cash flows
and reserves and our debt our bonds and
our ratings so I wrote we can do
questions and answers at the end but
um so all of you know what my office
does so we are a non-partisan
constitutional office
um we are responsible for the cash
Investments and
um the issuance of our general
obligation bonds or revenue bonds and
all the finance and activities that the
state
um is you know engages in and as part of
that we also have all the
responsibilities we managed and claim
property program we receive about I will
say about 20 million dollars from
holders from property holders each year
and we return about
um between six and seven million each
year to the rifle owners of that
property so last year we created about
15 million to the general fund so that's
about the amount that we credit each
year we also responsible for the 539
color savings program that continues to
be a successful program in the state
helping families stay for college right
now we have about 21 billion in assets
and the management again a very
successful program and that is um we
have that Administration with the
college tuition Savings Plan advisor
Commission
in a similar program that we have as a
smaller and a smaller scale is the
achieving a better life experience able
Savings Program so it is a similar
savings plan for individuals and
families with disabilities so that
program is growing I I have that
co-administration with the governance
Commission on disability and right now
we have 6.4 million in assets under
management about 800 accounts so that is
again I think families are realizing
what the benefits of the program are and
they're taking advantage of that and as
all of you know I serve on many multiple
boards and commissions so we just
essentially have our hands everywhere in
so um the good news is that in fiscal
year 22 we had a another remarkable year
in terms of of performance we we
continue to
um you know we continue that Trend as
you heard from commissioner uh stepp uh
Revenue so perform again and fiscal year
um again we just continues we just
continue to see that uh the recovery
from the pandemic you know caused by you
know all of the various factors are
really occurred as you know everyone was
trying to
um
improve the economy and 2021 between
monetary policy fiscal policy all of
that came together and all those States
benefited from from that so we obviously
the state did really well and so we had
a restrictive revenue of about 3.2
million billion dollars and that was
435.5 Million above plans about 15.6
percent so I know you heard from
commissioner stepped all of the the
performance of an individual taxes so
right now I'm going to focus on under 60
Revenue
um so we can see
um
um you know how the state uh performed
and and again all of these is
information do you already know I'm I'm
just simply recapping what was reported
in the annual comprehensive financial
report and that's um in the next three
slides
um
so so with that additional Revenue that
was above plan of course all you know
that you took advantage of that and
there were additional Appropriations
um that were um above and beyond what
was uh budgeted for fiscal year 22 and
23 there was about 140 million uh
designated for fiscal year 22 in about
175 million for fiscal 23. I might have
this 175 million
um not 100 that's an exact or estimate
but that's what I have from my records
perhaps you heard from um
LBA Mr Kane you know what that amount
was
um but with that
um you know we had um the general
education trust fund had an undissimated
balance so what we call surplus of uh
361 million and from that it was uh
253.3 million relative to general fund
and 108 million relative to the
education trust fund
and so the um the revenue civilization
account or rainy day fund finished the
year with 159 point million and that
compares to
257.8 million that we had in fiskier 22.
so we added 2.1 million of legal
settlement funds and also 100 million
was appropriated to the YDC settlement
funds so again is this information that
you already know and the next page is
how is presented in the
and the act for the fiscal year 22 I
just I'm including the table how is
presented and again it just shows
um how the unrestricted right now for
fiscal year 22
um how it includes the Appropriations it
includes some lapses and fiskier 222 of
about 104 million and
um again then the Signet of fund balance
all the way down is
253 million for the general fund 108 for
the education Fund in 360 1.3 million in
total and it shows again the activity
for the rainy day fund what I believe
the Comptroller's office wanted to show
in this case even though the 100 million
that is designated for the YDC
settlement fund that's applicable for
fiscal year 23.
um I know the controller's office wanted
to show that and and the ACT first so
it's separated at 100 million separately
from the rainy day fund so again we now
see and we're going to talk about the
renew the fund a little later in the
presentation but that is
um
what is presented in the aquifer didn't
the next page is also a piece this is a
table that is also including the Akron
this is how the controller's office was
trying to
um I guess percent the additional
Appropriations that happened
um that were in addition to the budget
so this table shows what was approved in
house bill one house bill two then again
those Appropriations the signal for
fiscal year 22 is 140 million for the
general fund
um and that is it also shows a few um I
guess adjustments and something that
caught my attention was some of those
105 million was um there was designated
for fiscuit 22 agencies are moving into
fiscal year 23
um so that's that must be encumbrances
in in all the transfers Appropriations
but what I wanted to show you with my my
uh my arrows hopefully I was successful
with that this total of
208 I'm not 200
um 2.8 billion
is what is the amount that is in the
table above
that
blue arrow there it's just showing
essentially all of the total
Appropriations and between those
Appropriations minus the lapses it gives
you what is being presented as total net
Appropriations hopefully I'm not
confusing anybody but
again an extraordinary year in fiscal
year 22 and that's what is being shown
so this is just a trend of unrestrictive
Revenue you can see how this span this
is understood terrain has been
um increasing increasing over time with
a few exceptions obviously we can see
um you know the performance in 2020
there was a decline decline in
performance but this I just wanted to
show you the 10-year Trend and this and
this next graph I I like to look at this
graph just because it shows the
performance and the revenue growth and
the city Revenue growth over time and I
like to I've been compiling data now and
and this shows
um the the performance since 2007 and as
you can see how um
and the Peaks that um decline in Peaks
it just shows how during those economic
downturns we we had that
significant declines in in 2009 we have
negative seven percent
um in 2020 we had negative six percent
um the other one anomaly that is is
presented here is really in 2004 when
um the revenue that we as was being
presented as unrestricted at that moment
which is the Medicaid enhancement tax
was changed and it was recharacterized
as restrictive Revenue so since then
it's been considered restrictive Revenue
but again the performance it just shows
how um how the state has performed over
time so a compound annual growth rate of
2.1 percent since 2007.
um again there's so much in this data it
could be again we have a combination of
economic downturns
um tax change tax change inches at
reductions in some taxes so it's really
perhaps there's a lot to analyze here
but it just shows how that performance
has occurred over time and of course we
have that peak in 2021 that shows uh 21
Revenue growth which is uh incredible
and then again in 2015 year 22 we had an
80 percent
um
growth over the prior year and then
fiscal year 23 based on what the revenue
fiscal year to date it looks like we are
revenue is about plan about 22 percent
and it's 3.5 percent uh over the prior
year so again another
um again fiscal year 22 was a strong
year fiscal year 22 it looks like fiscal
year 23 it looks like it's um
we are in a strong position to perhaps
so this is not an economic update and I
but I just wanted to include a few uh a
few economic indicators just to give you
a background of where things have been
and how you know the decisions that have
been made by central banks
um
the the Federal Reserve has two mandates
one is price stability the other one is
of Full Employment so because of that
they're looking at a variety of economic
factors and
um unemployment rate has been strong as
as you all know and especially in New
Hampshire we have a 2.6 rate and I know
you're going to hear from experts about
um how the economy has been and where
it's going but this is just to give you
an indication that unemployment rate and
and labor participation has been strong
the further service
they continue to watch that activity but
they feel comfortable with that piece
the Pisa obviously they're not
comfortable with is the inflation and
how inflation has changed since 2021 and
we can see that in December of 22 we had
an inflation of seven percent in the
beginning of our service was discussing
the fact that it was a it inflation was
transitory well at the end of last year
they started removing that that term and
and really start worrying about
inflation and sticky inflation
and so we saw in 22 how inflation
continued in the last um and so and
that's when the photos have started
increasing rates so in March of uh 22
the federal service started increasing
rates for the first time and after that
increased rates seven times and they've
been very aggressive with that
it appears that what they're doing
they're also trying to remove the size
of the balance sheet so all of the
pieces the the monetary policy policy
appears to be working inflation is
starting to come down and again we know
how all of this is started obviously the
the the fact that we have a war in
Ukraine
um impact Energy prices and it impacted
of food prices so all of that is is
starting to
um
balance a little better and again
obviously this is is not clear whether
it's inflation is going to
um
if it's going to continue to decline but
again this is this is this is the
factors that the everyone is is really
watching
um so Madam Treasurer could we interrupt
for just one moment for a quick question
while we're on this slide absolutely
thank you so much representative
Schamberg
thank you madam chair thank you madam
Treasurer uh how quickly are you
informed when the Federal Reserve makes
their decision to either raise or lower
interest rate so you can do
our policy here in this state
um we're we're very aware of what what
is happening
um all the time I mean it it's just not
and we'll talk about and about that in a
minute
um
do you prefer away okay okay sounds good
and then hopefully if that doesn't
answer your question I'll we can go back
to that perfect
so so that brings me to the next side
really
um
for anyone who's um not familiar with
the with this um the U.S uh treasure
yield curve perhaps
um
this is this is the the U.S treasury
yield curve it just shows what um is is
really the
um a representation of how rates are
short-term to long term and this is
something uh the financial markets uh
investors and everyone is is watching so
this is how investors are feeling the
the the the environment right now so uh
with the with the changes in the with
the changes that the Federal Reserve
hasn't been making
um
I guess a plus problem
um I just wanna um I guess try to
explain the chart
um if you look at the um the dotted line
the blue data line
um that represents the normal yield
curve and what that shows is that it
shows
um short-term rates are lower than the
than the long-term rates obviously if
you are invested in a short term you're
expected to be if you're if you invest
in long term you're expected to be
compensated at a higher yield when you
invest for a longer period of time so
this is what the normal yield Curve will
show but what's been happening with the
with the changes and and rates is as a
Federal Reserve as increasing rates the
U the the yield curve is changing so
it's putting all the pressure at the
front end of the curve and as you can
see the the blue the blue line that is
the activity at December 31st of 2022
you can see how the higher rates are the
front end of the curve and they are um
Chin Chin at the long term they're lower
um
so so so again what what the follower
server has been doing uh reducing the
size of their balance sheet and
increasing rates it's just changing how
this curve is is is being presented and
one of the things that that is interest
interest very interesting is how
um how the front end
and even when you see that the two-year
re the two-year yield and the is higher
than the 10-year yield that typical
represents
um what is an indication of a recession
so the markets have been predicting this
so and it's called the
um is called the um
that the the yield curve has inverted so
the Yale curb inverter for the first
time in April of 22 and then it diverted
again and July of 22. so since then the
markets have been predicting this
potential recession and that typically
happens between 6 and 12 months
um but again that could change you know
as as new economic data um
um changes in in in
it's available to investors in the
Federal Reserve obviously that that
performance can change but this is just
an indication of how things have changed
since last year and what the yield curve
looks like right now and that is um and
so we're we're aware of so the markets
can continuously talk about this they're
constantly discussing well what is the
Federal Reserve going to do so right now
there's expectation that the ferrissa
will continue to raise rates
um they've been very aggressive in the
very beginning but now they're expecting
to perhaps slow down for the rest of the
year
um
and um but but there's but they're
expected to continue to raise the raids
until they feel that they're tackled
inflation because their target their
their target is to bring inflation down
to two percent
um so this is this is what the market
the bond market investors are seeing
this is they they see that in the long
term rates are going to be about 3.96 4
range and this is what the market
predicting the predicting a recession
over the next
six to 12 months again it's hard to know
but that's the picture that we are all
um
the next jar is what the fervous service
thinking so every time they meet they
make decisions and
um every quarter they update their
economic
um projections so this is a chart that
shows
how they see rates over the next few
years so based on their information the
economic data that they captured
um they believe the inflation is going
to go down but they believe that they're
going to continue to increase rates so
the medium the the solar line here shows
the medium and this is when the Forester
meets they all discuss
um where they think rates are going to
be so in 23 they expect that the rate is
going to have a terminal rate of 5.1
percent and 23 they expect right now
that in 24 they're going to be about 4.1
percent uh and 25 they're going to be
about 3.1 percent and then just slower
over time and about
um
three and a half percent so there's a
difference between what the FED is
thinking and what the bond market or
what the investors are thinking as you
can see them the investors think well
it's going to be long term it's going to
be about four percent in the long run
the Foreign Service thinking less there
is uh obviously that debate that they
will have to decide or just over time
will know what really will happen but
this is just an indication of what we
are seeing and how we are
um again based on this information how
we're planning our our how we see the
economy will go based on um interest
rates
so with that in the background I'm going
to talk about cash flows and our
reserves
um so the good news is our cash position
and ourselves are very strong
um as you all know our cash position
changed dramatically over the last two
years
between revenue performance and then
because of all the stimulus money that
we received over the last two years
we have a position right now about we
went from between 200 and 800 million of
daily administration of cash to about
2.5 million in fiscal year 22 right now
we're about two two bill I keep saying
billion mixing the millions of billions
it's about two five two point five
billion dollars
so at the end of fiscal year 22 all all
funds combined we had about three
billion dollars in in our banks so
during fiscal year 22 we processed um
about 9.3 billion in deposits and we
dispersed about 8.4 billion in payments
and so as all you know we we also have
some trust in custodial accounts and
that and the Aggregates about 58 million
that was the balance at the end of
excuse us could we ask you a quick
question while we're here and then I
also need to manage the timeline
so we only have about five minutes left
because we never put another presenter
behind you but of course we welcome you
back to Ways and Means very soon to go
over this in even more detail but
representative Platt has a question yeah
is there a typo it says of June 30th
2023 cash is three billion dollars how
do you know what is June 30th 2023 it's
greatness
I'm sorry I I'm not I'm not sure where
cash flow and reserves uh the fourth
bullet I'm sorry yeah you're right it
should be 22.
and I apologize for not managing my time
um
I could um
um what I'll do is um just mention
um
the highlights um this um
because of our cash position has been
very strong
we have we haven't been investing our
fans
um in I guess I moved to um this slide
um this is where our cash flows look
like right now again we went from lower
levels to right now it's about
I'll stick with the charts this chart is
how um we've been um so again since we
we our cash position changed
dramatically over time we we redefine
and we refine our our investment policy
and so we are exploring
um different Investments now that will
allow us to maximize
um
the amount of cash we have in others in
in our x what we call access cash not
not uh not a reserves so a reserves is
what we will call it a rainy day fund so
um in terms of what um
in terms of the rainy day Farm we have
about
159.9
million in our reserves as you all know
um that has been that has increased over
time and and it is a strong it's a
strong is a strong number in even though
100 million was taken from
um last year we obviously continued to
have a strong Reserve uh in our in our
in our
um
for the state so one thing I want to
point out as some
um
this this particular slide talks about
the the maximum amount that we can hold
and and
um one way to look at that is right now
we we hold about 47 of what we are
allowed to haul in a rainy day fund
um 10 of the total revenue says what we
can call for the for the buy animals as
much as we can go we go about 47 percent
um but again one way to another way to
look at that is how you know how much
money we have on a researcher fund our
reserves and how the state will be able
to uh cover expenses if you only had
those reserves to to to continue
um uh operating so another way to look
at that is a number of days that
um
we could cover our expenditures with
demand that we have in our research so
this there's a research study done by
few terrible trusts and um they're
saying that the median is about 42.5
days and we have you know if you want to
cover the rain um the general funds we
we could cover about 36.
um 36.3 days and in order to cover both
the general funding expense and and
education trust fund expenditures we
will cover about
21.6 states of expenditure so again it's
just a quick another way to look at our
um
again we're investing already they found
it in a different way we just developed
a an investment policy for this now that
we have a lot more funds in there we're
trying to take advantage of we're so so
we we have a very similar investment
policy than we have for operating funds
uh which is Preservation of capital
liquidity in in we obviously want to
maximize the rate of return the
difference between the rainy day fund
and our operating funds is that um we
expect to have the renew the fund amount
the reserves longer in there and so the
way the average material or security is
obviously are longer than one year
so so there's a lot to to discuss about
interest as you all heard you know the
interest rates the good news is that
interest rates are are higher and with
that amount of cash that we have right
now we are earning interest for the
first time so we recorded interest in
fifth year 22 about only 3 million
um
fiscal year today we have recorded about
17 million and we expect to at least
have double the amount by the end of the
fiscal year we still need to refine our
estimates but that's what it looks like
so obviously um the rest of the other
two the biennium uh fiscuer 24 and 25
will depend on the average balance and
of our cash so uh but again you you've
been hearing about the yields how
perhaps those yields are going to be
over the next two years
um so we will have interest income for
um our debt has been decreasing over
time that's that's good news we have our
outstanding debt we've been paying that
debt um
again the train has been uh decline in
um the general obligation bonds are
um
again decline in turnpikes doesn't have
um they did a refunding this year they
haven't had a need to issue more bonds
and the other um the Garvey is is
another
um type of bond that we've just been
paying uh The Debt Service on that and
again it's been declining
um we are right now trying to um
try to determine how much money we're
gonna issue for bonds this year
um one key component of that is we
typically issue bonds based on Capital
expenditures well Capital expenditures
have been decline in because of all the
delays and projects so perhaps we're
going to issue less bonds and we're
trying to uh determine uh obviously the
amount but over the last two years those
Capital expenditures have been again
declining because of all the delays and
we issue a small amount in 2020 within
Nation 21 we should above what is 59
million and
um in 22 and right now expenditures what
we see for a couple of expenditures are
very low so we ex if we issue debt this
year it's going to be a very small
amount but
um
and a rating so I just want to jump to
the ratings
so um the good news we have very strong
ratings Square ratings and Moody's and
Fitch have affirmed the rate and so we
we have a strong rate with with them
last year s p Global ratings changed the
outlook for the stay from stable to
positive and that's because obviously
the economy are our financials have been
very strong
they obviously have been observing the
activity
uh are our revenues of performance
um they love the idea that we increase
the capacity for the Rainy they find
they love the idea that we added more
money to the rainy day fund
um so their um they outlook for the
state changed from stable to positive so
that's an indication that perhaps
they're considering an upgrade for us so
that would be wonderful news but
obviously they'll continue to monitor
and um
obviously the Rainy the um the raiding
agencies are in addition to look at all
our and I go back to one slide for a
moment in addition to looking at you
know the the the the cons they obviously
they look our rainy day fund balances
and and levels um the you know New
Hampshire has always been here to
obviously to balance the budget they
they they review the levels of Medicaid
expenditure how that increases
um how that provides
um or causes budgetary pressures the
levels of funding of the pension and you
have liabilities obvious that they are
concerned about that
um they also like to see
um you know our ability to manage our
revenues our expenditures and reserves
so the flexibility that the state will
have but again we've received what we
call credit positive and so again that's
the reason that we've been have we
continue to have an accelerate uh
something that they're watching
something to watch is obviously their
rain ages are watching macroeconomic
conditions
um how we're going to respond to this
lower economy how we're going to respond
to this sticky inflation perhaps higher
borrowing cost
um in you know other factors that they
review is how the city of New Hampshire
for example is going to manage
additional funding that is going to be
for infrastructure is is how the state
is taking advantage of that additional
funding and and how that will benefit
our state and how we're going to take
advantage of all that how the state
manages additional risk you know new
threats have a secure risks as I
mentioned at that last time we met
new rests you know cryptocurrency see
how we are responding to regulation
relative to that and and how we
responded to extreme weather you know
what are the measures that we provide
climate resilience
um so so with that I think that ends my
presentation I went through very quickly
uh but with that um just so I want to
mention
um s p for example foresee is a
recession a shallow recession and they
believe in general that Public Finance
or states are going to be able to
weather that because of the strong
strong economy that we've had and the
financial conditions that we currently
have so yeah that yet to see so I
apologize for the time
um but but thank you for having me and
I'll be happy to answer any questions if
there's time for that thank you so much
are there any very quick questions
representative Army
thank you on I know some a number of the
things that where we're compared with
other states only look at our general
fund
do the Credit Agencies also look at our
education trust fund
and the highway fund
to a lesser extent um they do I mean
they know that the the the revenue is
restricted to the the revenue that is
um
or the education trust fund is
restrictive for that purpose so what
they really review is are you know
flexible on restricted revenue and and
so how that increases and because
obviously that provides greater
flexibility for the state for again all
of those pieces that could create
budgetary pressures they are constantly
worried about well how the states
responding to those changes emergencies
new programs you know you create you
generate enough Revenue to to to pay for
those new programs and new initiatives
and things like that so could I just I
didn't quite understand so the education
trust fund even though we can take money
out of it and put money into it uh from
the general fund is not considered while
they're looking at this they do look at
it as just it's just considered
restricted and so again they pay more
attention to the unrestrictive portion
uh what is called the net
again this they look at the ability for
issuers of bonds to be able to pay debt
service you know this is this is a
credit
um credit rating that is presented to
investors so our ability to generate
Revenue so our ability to pay our net
tax supported debt those are the things
that they pay close attention to thank
you very much Senator link that wasn't a
question just a comment to some of the
members so one of the things she talked
the treasure talked about was 100
million withdrawal from the rainy day
fund while at the same time we're
talking about how great the revenue is
doing and we're making all kinds of
money across all of our tax revenues and
I just want to remind especially the
freshmen that 100 million dollars was
the sununu center it was an offset to
put aside for the lawsuit against the
new news center and all those cases and
so we withdrew from the rainy day fund
100 million dollars instead of the side
to deal with any of those lawsuits so
just you didn't think we took money out
because it was raining it was just a
potential rainstorm that was coming and
we set it aside and plan for it just
just quickly to add to that I mean to
take the time but
um that is something I had to have a
conversation with a rating agencies and
they I did explain to them it was it was
it was a rainy day
um but obviously the question that came
back um to to me to us to all of us is
what does it say what are they say what
are the plans to replenish that amount
if there's a plan to replenish obviously
they're interested in increasing our
reserves because it's a way for them to
to see how New Hampshire is going to
respond to a potential recession so the
more money we have on our reserves and
our cash position
the better prepared we're going to be to
face or mitigate a recession
we will be more competitive and
attractive than the neighboring states
because that's how we're going to do it
thank you very much
speaking of being better economically
than our neighboring states we have to
recognize I hope he's here commissioner
Taylor Caswell is the first commissioner
of the New Hampshire Department of
Business and economic Affairs he was the
first appointed by the governor in the
position in 2017 and he serves as the
chief economic and marketing official
for the state and oversees the state
divisions of Economic Development and
travel and tourism
Mr caswell's experience in the private
sector includes structuring and funding
Renewable Power and affordable housing
development financial services and
government relations for a Fortune 500
Energy company
and he grew up in Littleton where he
founded uh the Parker Mountain Trails
and does a lot of mountains we still
live in Littleton fabulous so there's
probably a lot more here but welcome
great thank you uh representative and
it's good to see everybody it's nice to
be back in person uh for this
conversation uh what I wanted to do
today was sort of set the stage I think
maybe for
um uh where we are strategically and on
a big picture uh with the state economy
and what we are doing at my department
in coordination with others across the
state to facilitate the advancement of
our competitive advantages in New
Hampshire as you so aptly put it
um
so just real quickly I mean and I know
you're going to hear from my friends
rich lavers and uh Brian gotlab and Ken
Johnson after after uh the lunch hour
they will be able to provide you a good
deal of granular data around all the
sort of subjects that I'm going to
discuss with you briefly here this
morning but just as a quick overview for
those of you who are maybe new to the
committee our department uh as
representative Sanborn pointed out uh is
the chief marketing organization so that
explains maybe some of our flashy slides
we have a lot of creative materials to
use for those sorts of things but we do
all the states marketing around tourism
hospitality and I'll talk a little bit
more about that but we also have the
division of Economic Development and
this is a larger organization within the
department that is focused heavily on
business retention business recruitment
we handle the international relations
for the state we have our office of
Workforce opportunity which works on the
workforce develop development end of
things and uh and a few other entities
within Bea that all together have been
our own entity since 2017. so a lot of
these functions were handled
individually at the former Department of
Revenue and economic or not Revenue
Department of resource and economic
development
formerly known as dread we've been in in
so I would say just just kind of
headline here the top two challenges
that we're facing from a policy
standpoint and from an economic
standpoint in the state remain Workforce
and uh and housing so those are two
areas that I'm going to focus a little
bit on today and then again you'll be
able to hear some more about the
different components of that and how
they all go together uh after lunch
so this very basic slide of the
unemployment rate I put this here really
because it's a good measure there's
obviously a lot more to analyzing uh the
health of the economy but this one I
think really sort of demonstrates for us
at least on a standard that we see
across a multitude of different states
and across the United States that New
Hampshire remains highly competitive
from a from a from a standpoint of
available Workforce and when we work
with companies and we work with
companies that are either looking to
expand here or looking to move here this
is the first question we get what about
the workforce and how are we going to be
able to access a Workforce for the work
that we're doing and that is something
that we obviously work very closely with
partners of the University system and
Community College system and with New
Hampshire employment services and others
sort of make those components go
together for the employers that we're
foreign
the other as I mentioned and something
that I'll I'll talk a little bit more in
detail about uh in a minute or two is is
the housing situation this is a map that
shows uh from New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority
where things stand as far as rental
metrics in the state and you know we're
at a 1500 per month median gross rent we
have a 0.3 and in some cases even lower
than that vacancy rate for uh housing
units across the state this is remains
our number one challenge in my view
because when we start talking about what
are the issues around Workforce we have
jobs we have people that fill those jobs
in a lot of places we have access to
people who want to live here and take
advantage of these jobs we see data that
supports all of that and it is uh the on
the ground sort of experience of our
staff that we are seeing that if we
don't have places for people to live and
we don't have adequate sort of steps of
people or places for people to live so
in other words come in looking for an
efficiency apartment maybe move to a two
bedroom three bedroom and then buy a
house all of those markets uh are seeing
a real Challenge and they continue to
see that challenge nothing new we've
been facing this for some time but it is
definitely accelerated and it's a lot
more obvious in the environment that
we're in right now and I would also
point out of course that we are not the
only state facing this challenge but
when people say that to me I say well
then that means that we need to solve it
faster than anyone else
um and I'll talk some more about those
um
tourism another major function of our
department
we have been since we were established
back in 2017 really working to integrate
the messaging that we do for tourism
with the work that we do to attract
Workforce and attract businesses to New
Hampshire a lot of the quality of life
components that we all know and love
here are things that are very appealing
to all of those audiences and in fact in
a lot of the research that we do we it
does we do see a very common
representation of having access to the
quality of life and the outdoor
activities as being a major driver for
people who either want to visit here for
a weekend or people who want to move
here or start a business here or move
their business here it is a common uh
strategy that we have really tried to
accelerate over the last few years and I
think to some success we do see
increases in numbers of people that have
come to the state that are look looking
to come to the state we can demonstrate
that in net migration numbers that over
the last five years have seen increases
for New Hampshire particularly in
younger demographics Mr Johnson will
probably be able to speak to you a
little bit about that a little later
today
but we do really work hard to make those
pieces all flow together while also
supporting our very important tourism
industry uh the other only other point I
would make on this slide is we do
calculate the return on investment that
we make with the marketing funds that we
do receive from the legislature we are
currently somewhere between 14 and 15
dollars returned to the state in terms
of meals and rentals revenue for every
dollar that we spend in our marketing
budgets
um well you know I said the last thing
second last thing on this really is also
that uh we have been using this strategy
for many years and in fact you could go
back uh many years in New Hampshire's
history and see that using tourism and
using the outdoor activities as a
marketing strategy not just for uh
tourism but also for the wider aspects
of our economy is nothing terribly new
but I would say that we are seeing a a
much larger audience that is receptive
to this message after the experience of
covet we have a lot of individuals and
families that are in urban areas
particularly in the Northeast that are
seeing the value of quality of life and
they are looking at New Hampshire as an
opportunity for them and of course this
ties back to the issues that we spoke
about earlier but that continues to be
something that we can demonstrate that
we're seeing progress
uh another very simple just sort of
overview of the change in visitation
versus 2021 and spend rates you see fall
really continues to be a very uh a very
uh important season for the State of New
Hampshire
um we see this in both Drive markets but
also in in international and long-haul
markets from areas like Texas and
Florida people come for a short a very
focused period of time uh winter is a
industry as we're experiencing this year
and then the spring and summer numbers
the summer numbers are a little lower
this year that's not that unusual we see
a very consistent number in our in our
in our summer numbers and we had a huge
bump in 20 in 2020 and 2021 which is uh
reflected that uh here in this number
the 2022 we saw those numbers starting
to return a little bit more towards a
normal visitation statistic
and this I put here just for uh this was
our projection that we've made for uh
this current season that we're in uh of
course we had this projection was done
with some variables related to weather
but uh the the lack of snow particularly
in the extreme North country has has
been a challenge thus far this year uh
the snowmobiling industry in particular
not seeing a lot of product to be able
to ride on although I would say for
anyone who's watching the skiers are
doing fine they are able to make a lot
of snow and it's very worth coming to
New Hampshire for the long weekend and
maybe getting in some skiing
um I wanted to uh quickly run through an
overview here this is something that I'm
happy you know and some of you have seen
me talk about this before and it's
something we'll continue to talk about
as we go through the session but our
economic recovery and expansion strategy
this was something that we put together
late 2020 early 21 we're still operating
from this it's designed obviously in in
in in light of the pandemic to be a
strategy that recognizes that the world
of Economic Development and Community
Development feels very different than it
did uh in 2019 and so we've been trying
really hard to stay ahead of the curve
using components of this strategy to
make investments in design programs that
give New Hampshire that competitive
advantage over the states that we
compete with for economic investment
five major goals this is very high level
this is all on our website
and something that has a lot of backup
material in it if you're interested in
looking at that some of these are pretty
obvious and I've talked about almost all
of these here recruiting and retaining
amount the workforce the connection of
Tourism the recruitment uh building
resiliency in our high growth sectors
high growth right now sectors are there
are several but life science Health Care
manufacturing tourism continues to be in
that space Advanced manufacturing and so
on those are areas that we continue to
see growth but also potential for
additional investment which those two
together it really kind of forms what
we're most interested in working and and
focusing on I should say
uh entrepreneurship and then the
infrastructure piece I would also point
out here uh that isn't just roads and
bridges that's things like Broadband uh
and the ability to have a state that has
access to high-speed internet in the
21st century uh now that we're what 20
through it uh it remains a really
critical component to the overall
Recruitment and Retention strategies uh
as anyone will tell you we're working on
people working remotely people being
able to live in a small town and work
for a firm that might not have a huge
presence in New Hampshire but they're
getting paid uh by that firm and they're
spending that money in a local community
these are all things that aren't
necessary and are part of what I was
saying earlier about that
what looks different about economic and
Community Development in New Hampshire
after the pandemic that certainly is one
of them when we start to take those
things uh those five key areas and we
break them down into the functions that
the department really sort of works with
our collaborative Partners to uh to to
advance those initiatives these are the
eight areas that again guide uh where we
go with those sort of things and I I
know we're short on time so I'm not
going to go through all of these uh
independently uh again I've spoken to
most of these and there are areas where
we must have relationships and
collaborations both with our fellow
state agencies but with local and
Regional officials municipalities and
with other economic development
organizations around the state and one
of the ways that we do that which is
part of this economic strategy or what
we call collaborative Economic
Development regions we have four of
these across the state we've developed
these over the last couple of years they
are forums for all of those partners
that I just mentioned to take part in
contribute and help us regionalize a lot
of those five high-level strategies that
we mentioned earlier and put actionable
strategies into place this has been a
huge benefit to us to be able to
effectively leverage the uh the ability
for the state to give support to this
type of activity to take some common
strategies and say we feel free strongly
that we need to go through that door not
that door for right now but um we get on
the other side that door things might
look different in the North country than
they do on the Seacoast so we want to be
able to regionalize some of the activity
that we do
and give those strategies a flavor that
actually has an applicability and a
value to employers and organizations in
that region so the Cedars are a big
function of that this slide gives a
little more detail I guess in terms of
what we actually do with them
they have received some resources from
us to be able to to advance some
specific initiatives in their areas and
this has been I can't emphasize this
enough because one of the things that
was missing from New Hampshire for many
years was what I referred as the
economic development infrastructure for
the state the systems that are in place
to be able to advance common initiatives
and strategies that make sense that the
state is seeing a value based in data
based in not somebody just sort of
picking something and throwing a dart
against the wall but these are high
value targets high value strategies and
then to have the support of
organizations like Regional development
corporations or planning commissions or
local municipalities that have Economic
Development offices getting in Chambers
of Commerce getting these organizations
to all sort of see a common vision and
be able to look towards ways to make
those things happen in their own way has
been a big success and I think it will
continue to be particularly if we end up
moving in a downtrend in our economy
uh I was obviously going to mention uh
the program that we uh started earlier
about mid-year last year the invest NH
housing program uh this is something uh
where we have already started to deploy
60 million dollars under the capital
Grant component of this program uh this
is a pretty exciting opportunity to
advance a number of different projects
30 in fact separate projects around the
state that are going to result in 900
new affordable units uh in New Hampshire
these are rental units new build across
the state not just in any one area but
we've gotten them geographically diverse
and then with the uh with that Capital
grant program are a number of programs
that we are instituting to help support
municipalities uh in uh engaging in a
process to consider how to bring more
housing to their Community how it might
fit there if it works in that community
and if it does what are some ways that
we can help incentivize and cover some
of the us that may come with that either
strategically or in the long term so
these programs are also available and
we're working with different
municipalities around the state we have
a separate website for this program it's
invest603.com again there's a lot more
lastly I did mention Broadband this is a
pretty uh this is a program that for
those of you who don't have Broadband is
a really big issue and for those of you
who don't who already have it is
congratulations I think that that's
great but we have a lot of areas of the
state that continue to not have access
to high-speed internet and this is a
I've referred to it as a once in a
lifetime opportunity to bring a
significant amount of federal resource
to bear on this issue and to get as many
unserved and underserved locations
around the state hooked up as quickly
and as efficiently as we possibly can we
have already deployed 60 million dollars
of the 122 million that we were awarded
under the arpa funds for this specific
purpose those funds are already being
spent to expand into areas that are
unserved and underserved and under the
contract that we awarded to the New
Hampshire Electric Co-op for that
purpose we expect to see 23 000 new
locations getting high-speed internet in
rural areas of the state we will be
awarding sometime in the next few weeks
the second round of that program which I
expect we'll see somewhere between 15
and 18 000 additional new locations
bringing us almost 40 000 new locations
getting high-speed internet in areas
that in some cases have not seen
anything better than dial up for decades
so in terms of the capability that this
brings to recruit and retain a Workforce
for employers to be able to access the
internet to do their business to help
individuals and and elderly reach their
doctors using Telehealth and video
Services the list is somewhat endless
and the internet is a very very critical
component of all Commerce in the state
and if we can move quickly as we are and
get those changes and get those
Investments made quicker than States we
compete with we will see the value of
that once again again for a long time to
come
so again that's me we've been through a
whole bunch of stuff there's a lot more
there obviously I look forward to
talking with you as the session goes on
as I mentioned uh my friend Brian gotlab
and others will have more to add to
these same components as we as you go
through your day but I'm happy to answer
any questions commissioner thank you so
much there's a question behind you
because as I'm looking at your rate
functional areas critical for economic
development I noticed that energy costs
and a nationally competitive tax
structure are not bullets would you
would you tell us why that's those are
not folk eye of your group I wouldn't
say they're not uh Foci we certainly
recognize the value of our tax program
and it is a major component of what we
do in terms of Recruitment and Retention
so the value of our tax structure
should not be understated
and I guess some ways it's been so much
part of the culture of the work that we
do that maybe it didn't get its own line
here but it is definitely uh definitely
a component in terms of energy this is a
challenge much like housing that we are
not alone in facing and I think that
there's there's been some Market
some Market reaction at least on the
commercial side to the fact that we do
have high energy rates in in New
Hampshire and in New England generally
so we have seen maybe a decline in the
type of heavy industry that that we saw
through many many decades back you know
going back sometime now and we're seeing
an increase in terms of businesses in
the tech space or in life sciences or in
other areas that maybe have a lower
cost per dollar of investment let's say
in energy than some of those heavy and
Street manufacturers so there there's an
adaptation that's occurring and we don't
spend a lot of time going after like big
metal manufacturers to locate in New
Hampshire but we do spend a lot of time
trying to get uh you know New Life
Science companies to come here to New
Hampshire because the access to a
world-class Workforce exists and because
you know there are other aspects to that
business type that um that recognize
that in particular the energy issue
you're welcome representative McGuire is
also behind you yeah
so there was an article in the union
leader recently that said that 16 of all
home sales in the state go to people
moving here from Massachusetts and
that's greater than the sum of all
people moving here from all of other
states so that implies that 50 of your
marketing should be directed at
Massachusetts is that what you're doing
I I don't know if it's 50 percent dead
on but for sure Massachusetts uh
Connecticut and we have we have
increased our uh our presence in the New
York area as well over over the last
couple of years but no question uh
Boston in particular and you know again
connecting that to the type of
businesses that we're seeing with the
highest level of growth and the high
high quality high education needs of
those uh of those individuals it fits
very nicely
representative Army
thank you uh two things that I
always find lacking in this uh one on
the taxation side that businesses pay
property taxes and property taxes are
two-thirds of our tax system and we pay
no attention to that usually in this
body
um and I don't know if you've had
conversations with businesses that were
calculating and if you go after
businesses that don't need much real
property
in order to function here but the other
one is that
there is on
the people in this state that earn under
the median
um we have fewer and fewer of them
willing to work in the services that
maintain the infrastructure and the
recreation and the general quality of
life of the ones that are in the higher
income brackets and
living in Lebanon as I do which on I
just noticed your chart says that
Grafton County as a whole has the
highest increase in housing costs and
the second highest amount of housing
cost in the state and most of that is my
area yes uh then on
the we have a extraordinary number of
young people that have come to work in
our startups and in Dartmouth medical
and in Dartmouth College on who on are
always on the internet complaining we
have no target we have no place to go in
the evening on we can't get anybody to
repair the gadget in our house that
broke uh and or to put in a new heating
system on and
there we we have been training aside
from the housing problem which is huge
we have been training people for 30
years in our schools not to want to do
that kind of thing to be told that
success means you go to college and so a
whole bunch of kids drop out and start
doing drugs representative is there a
question there yes uh can you possibly
uh
talk about whether you are working with
companion groups and other departments
about these problems
yes on all of them and I agree with the
many of the points you made
representative as usual I think
um Lebanon certainly is a very popular
area and I think many reasons why there
are challenges in in particular that
area but it's not unique there are same
challenges in all parts of the state in
terms of Workforce and Workforce
training we absolutely work very closely
with the community college system and
our CTE
programs around the state and look for
opportunity opportunities to invest both
either in terms of technical resource
but actually in financial dollars in
those programs to do a lot of things
you've just said
the the degree to which uh we have
challenges in services and Hospitality
all continue to remain I would say
there's been a little glimmer of hope in
the service industry nationally speaking
anyway we don't have the the most recent
data for New Hampshire yet but there is
some hope I think and people coming back
to the some of those jobs uh on a
national scale we'll hope that we see
similar Trends here in New Hampshire but
uh there are questions and I think
you'll see one of the slides that I'm
pretty sure Brian always likes to show
that you'll see after lunch is uh where
the Gap is in terms of the individuals
who are have not returned to the
workforce we have not yet quite gotten
to where we were at 2019 in terms of
individuals working in the you know res
the residents of New Hampshire are
working and there's a specific
population that uh that falls into that
category a lot of times it has to do
with whether or not individuals have
responsibilities for others in their
family so that gives you I think a very
uh uh look at either end of the
workforce age Spectrum so we continue to
try to find ways to get those
individuals back into the workforce to
make up some of the Gap but I have to
say probably in the end if we got every
single person
uh in New Hampshire who's not working
who could be working working we'd still
have a gap so
um the challenges remain I think the
tools that we have at our disposal are
training and giving people opportunities
to see the value of I mean if you were
an electrician anywhere in the North
Country these days you'd probably be
doing pretty well uh yeah I know one in
Littleton is telling me that they don't
even think about coming out until April
at this point for that type of work and
you've got companies that are able to
really pick and choose the type of areas
that they're in based on the reality so
representative Elber
thank you madam chair
um I representative uh Ward one in
Nashua uh I have when I was campaigning
I spoke with a good many people who were
talking about how they live in Nashville
but they can't afford to work in Nashua
teachers who can earn twenty thousand
dollars a year more by just going across
the border
um what are we doing in terms of or
what's your office doing in terms of
looking at salaries
Nashua for example was looking for a
master's level speech pathologist
paying forty nine thousand dollars a
year now my own research showed me that
the average one-bedroom apartment in
Nashua was seventeen hundred dollars a
month which meant that the growth more
than 20 percent of that
staff member's salary would be going
toward rent
how are we approaching the fact that
employers aren't paying enough to be
able to allow people to afford to work
here well I think I would say a good
thing well first of all employers if
they are experiencing shortages in their
Workforce typically will find the among
the tools they have to attract the
workforce is paying more and that's
something that uh we certainly uh remind
them of as much as we as we can but I
would say on the other side uh with
regard to the housing component again
this goes uh to the most basic need of
any individual which is to have housing
that that matches
the basic income levels in an area and
that's where we have some capability to
at least raise the issue we have a
hundred million dollars that we're
putting towards this program uh through
the invest in age program and that just
scratches the surface right I think
there are a multitude of reasons that
you can get into as to what causes all
these things to happen most of which the
government doesn't have a lot of control
over but we can make some Investments
and demonstrate that by by making some
Investments by making some
alterations to local policies to be able
to accommodate those individuals that we
can make some progress in affecting the
vacancy rates which in which will in
turn affect the total rent costs that
are in any individual community
you're welcome
thank you madam chair uh thank you for
taking my question uh work participation
rate versus uh say 20 or 30 years ago
was on a decline and how do you
determine that that right I don't know I
can't I can't say specifically that uh I
can I can riddle off the top of my head
what the labor participation rates were
uh at that rate but we do have uh
nationally one of the highest labor
participation rates we were in the 70s
last I saw
um and again I'm pretty certain you're
going to see a slide from Brian on that
this is an area that he really focuses
on because we we have seen that slip
thank you so much if there any other
questions as representative Bolton
thank you madam chair um regarding
housing
um I live in Plymouth and there
um is some wrestling over the language
of zoning changes that must be put in
place in order to encourage Workforce
housing or affordable housing is there
model language that yep you've been
producing that you could share so I
would say uh it would be easy to connect
them to me and I will get them to the
right place but it is we have staff but
we also work with New Hampshire Housing
and New Hampshire housing has actually
some funding that is available through
our invest in h program to help
local communities that want to make some
analysis or review or changes to their
zoning rules to to participate in the
program at no cost
so that's a worthy program to look at
but if you want to send them to me I'm
taylor.caswell nh.gov pretty easy
thank you very much just send them to me
wonderful presentation we appreciate you
coming here today everyone you should
take a break until one o'clock and then
come back and then we will get
demographic information which is what
you've been asking about so thank you
I've been building them up pretty heavy
so
beautiful
foreign
hi
good afternoon
time being one o'clock we should
probably get started it's actually 102.
welcome back to the 2000 no 2023 joint
economic briefing uh we have special
guests uh Rich lavers from the Deputy
Commissioner of the Department of
Employment Security and Brian Gottlieb
the director of Economic and labor
market information and both of you
hopefully will educate us on the state's
labor market among other things so we
all right well thank you so much so we
do everyone should have copies of the
slides that Brian and I will be working
from so I'll kick us off I'll talk for a
little bit hopefully not too much uh
Brian will then present we'll go back
and forth and then Brian will have the
big finish
um really trying to set up those
expectations for his part of the
presentation here and deflate mine so
um but let's get let's get started
so
um I'll multitask here I'll work the
computer and talk at the same time so
our first slide that that folks have and
uh trying just to put everything into
context for what we've experienced
coming out of the pandemic caused
recession from a labor force perspective
you can see here that we have a
comparison of of how the state did
coming out of the Great Recession
compared to the labor force recovery
coming out of the pandemic so when we
when we look at labor force recovery and
we look at that Peak recession
labor force number it took us nearly
seven years to get back to that Peak
coming out of the Great Recession you
compare that to how quickly we were able
to recover private sector employment
lost during the pandemic session we're
looking at about two and a half years so
really no comparison between the two
hard to put the two of them on the same
chart but we felt it was important to
show how quickly things occurred from a
labor force perspective both uh on the
on the downturn back in 2020 and then
how quickly the state has been able to
recover private sector employment coming
out of the pandemic caused recession
how New Hampshire is doing compared to
other states so again looking at our
private sector employment and right now
you see New Hampshire the Red Bar you
also see that we've noted our other New
England states but New Hampshire is a
little bit over one percent above where
we were in our pre-pandemic Peak again
for private sector employment
and you see Maine is is right up there
with New Hampshire in terms of having
recovered all of its private sector
employment and then some other New
England states are are not there yet you
see where Massachusetts is Connecticut
Rhode Island and Vermont still have some
distance to go in terms of recovering
that lost private sector employment and
but puts it into perspective of how New
Hampshire fares compared to the rest of
the Northeast
now I could tell you that everyone is
happy every sector has shared in that
recovery equally but we all know that is
not the case and what this next slide
presents to you is a breakdown of
employment gains and losses
compared back to pre-pandemic and how
each of our sectors are doing from the
perspective of the number of jobs in
that sector for this slide what we use
for numbers are taken from our quarterly
census of employment and wages so these
are the actual reports filed by New
Hampshire businesses that have
employment they file that on a quarterly
basis when they report
their employees and the wages paid to
Employment Security as part of the
unemployment insurance
tax system
so that's where this data is coming from
and here you can see the sectors that
have had the the largest amount of
growth with our our professional
scientific and Technical Services so
there's a lot of I.T occupations in this
sector
um Architects legal engineering so a lot
of higher paying type of professions
um in in this sector that have had the
most growth construction has fared well
from an employment perspective and then
as we move down this chart you can see
those sectors that have shed employment
and those that have had a more difficult
time than others in getting back to
where they were prior to the pandemic
and you can see down at the bottom of
this chart those sectors that have lost
the most employment you see a lot of our
health care sector so long-term care
facilities hospitals those are
continuing to have the the hardest time
of getting back to where they were
pre-pandemic state government is also
down there we've we've highlighted that
in the in the red bar and then our
retail employers as well still
significantly down the next
two slides try to put that together
could we while we're on that slide could
we would you entertain questions
absolutely excellent Center thank you
madam chair do you know it uh do you
track child care as one of the sectors I
don't see them on here but we've heard
that there's about a 50 percent decline
in capacity
so there and and Brian will chime in
here too so Child Care is part of the
social assistance sector
um and how it is tracked here
um number of establishments in terms of
um those that are providing care
um and the number of workers what do we
have currently Brian
um we're down in the number of providers
we're probably down in terms of
employment somewhere between 10 to 20
percent probably I would say probably
closer to 15 percent in terms of
employment that's a national Trend by
the way
um nationally it it has been rebounding
somewhat we don't keep track of the
number of spaces in that's something
that I think the Department of Health
and Human Services tracks that we don't
have that we do have the number of
employees
and we do have some additional there are
some other slides that we'll we'll touch
upon that too as well senator this is a
representative behind you representative
games
this chair doesn't make the distinction
between part-time and full-time
employment and you're absolutely correct
we did see a lot of businesses that that
ceased operating during the pandemic a
lot of retail a lot of food services
restaurants did as well but one of the
things that we don't have this
unfortunately in this particular
presentation but we do in others the
number of businesses that have started
up new businesses that have come to
replace those businesses has really been
remarkable we've seen some of the
highest levels of new business starts in
our state in the times that I've been
looking at the data which is at least a
couple of decades so we've replaced a
representative leapley thank you madam
chair just a question this graph is I'm
assuming this number is number of jobs
so how does that that is correct
[Music]
um it's hard for me to understand what
six thousand jobs gained or lost means
can you kind of help translate that for
me that is a perfect segue into the next
chart thank you so much representative
while we're here though we have a
question from representative almie
didn't want to get in the way but on
we've we've got a lot of former
employees of head to restaurants that
have founded their own places and are
now discovering they don't have enough
people work to work for them but um I
wanted to ask about state government
does that include municipal
that does not
so they're just not on the chart they're
not on the chart I will I will say
um
interesting because I just did a another
presentation this morning where I did
look at local government and local
government is around the same number of
declines and when I look at local
government I'm excluding educational
services so it's not counting schools
just looking at the the executive uh
portion of local government and it's
down somewhere in the order of between
14 and 1500 as well
thank you
representative Rutherford thank you
madam chair um just looking at the
losses again the job losses uh as it
relates to the nursing nursing and
Residential Care Facilities hospitals
Health Care
um
are you attributing are you able to
attribute that to burnout of employees
because clearly these facilities are are
would hire if they could
and this this data set doesn't capture
that right but certainly with
um not only anecdotal evidence but with
the stories that we hear and talking
with those employer groups certainly
burnout is a big factor
um with that service sector type work
particularly in healthcare we do see
quit rates in the healthcare industry
have risen sharply traditionally they've
had lower quit rates among all
Industries
Hospitality has high quit rates retail
has high quit rates traditionally
Healthcare has low crit rates it has
increased very sharply post pandemic and
during the pandemic the other thing that
we attribute this to we know that
there's job openings in the healthcare
industry it is perennially at least in
the last few years been at the top of
the list of job openings in the state so
it's not a function of lack of demand
it's a function of lack of Supply in in
the field build occupations
and that was going back prior to the
pandemic you know registered nurses are
one of the most high demand occupations
when we look at posting data and that
you know that was true before the
pandemic it's even
um more so true now
representative fellows thank you um can
you tell me if in particular like the
nursing
bar if it includes the traveling nurses
the ones that come here on work for our
agency and come here on a you know
short-term basis that that would be in a
in a different industry that would be
because they're generally hired by
um though they belong to employment
service organizations
um so they're not technically employed
specifically by a health care provider
but rather by some sort of employment
agency so they tend to they fall into
um the administrative and support
services which is includes um temporary
help agencies so the occup the
occupation itself
um actually hasn't shrunk that much it's
just that the demand has been so high
and the the demand is a little bit more
Diversified as well and and talking
about some of it shifting to the the
temporary uh type of Occupational
providers but also looking at other
non-health care type of employers who
have positions requiring that that
nursing skill set
um so you see a lot of that occupational
skill set in those other sectors as well
because the the amount of hiring that's
being done of that occupational skill
set is about the same as it was right
prior to the pandemic it's just a lot of
it is being done outside of the health
care sector people like organizations
like Walmart CVS
you know retail operators are hiring
Health Care Providers they're hiring
nurses they're hiring pharmacists so
that's not showing up in these in the
healthcare Industries it is showing up
in the occupational data which is a
um so trying to put this into
perspective so you know great question
6600 job gains
um do I care about that what is that in
relationship to the to the sector to the
state's private sector employment base
um does it matter
um here you can see when we look at the
gains and losses as a percentage of
those sectors
um and what those numbers uh from that
from that prior slide actually translate
to for the significance within that
sector so again uh professional
scientific and Technical Services being
at the top in terms of gains you can see
that that gains about a 17
gain in terms of employment within that
sector and then we look at our sectors
that have lost you see that our our
social assistance down a little over
seven percent long-term care facilities
in nursing and residential being down
eight and a half half percent
in hospitals down close to six percent
so you can see what those gains and
losses represent to that sector and in
our our next slide we look at what those
sectors mean for total private sector
employment within the state so here you
can see what percentage or what share
each of these sectors is in terms of the
amount of employees that they have as a
percentage of the state's total private
sector employment base
foreign
moving right along here so
um looking at what the activity is uh
currently experiencing right now in the
unemployment program you'll see that
here in this slide that the initial
claims for unemployment so people filing
that initial claim having lost covered
employment being through no fault of
their own those initial claims are
significantly down when we compare that
to prior to the pandemic you know the
pandemic period kind of throws all
comparisons out when we look at the fact
that we had 175 000 people filing we
paid more benefits in two years than we
did in the entire prior decade so when
we look back at prior to the pandemic
and we look at those initial claims New
Hampshire is about 40 percent
below where we were for initial claim
volume compare that to the the country
as a whole
um not really the case uh nationally in
terms of that large of a decline in
initial claims nationally down about 10
percent
when we look at
weekly claims so payable claims claims
that an individual is filing as they
continue to be unemployed and seeking
unemployment benefits those that that
volume's about 36 percent below where we
were prior to the pandemic that now
these both both of these charts are a
four-week moving average this data comes
out every Thursday
um so it's a nice high frequency metric
for us to look at and compare against
pre-pandemic but New Hampshire down 36
and weekly weekly claims in the
unemployment program you compare that
against our neighbor to the South with
Massachusetts they're down about seven
percent and nationally that's down about
16 so again New Hampshire is an outlier
with regard to the significant decline
in utilization of the unemployment
program throughout 2022 when we compare
um so not only are our claims down in in
New Hampshire near record lows but also
our duration so the the length of time
that someone is filing an unemployment
claim that is significantly down as well
this slide tries to put that into
perspective and you can see that New
Hampshire has about the fifth lowest
average duration at about 10 weeks we
compare that out against our other New
England neighbors
um and you can see that New Hampshire
really
um is an outlier in the Northeast for
the duration of an average unemployment
and getting into some of the other
um uh questions about the increased
demand for labor
um so what you can what you can see here
from a quarterly perspective is how uh
New Hampshire has increased the number
of employers
going back to prior to the pandemic so
these are employers that are providing
employment in New Hampshire they
register with Employment Security as is
required for purposes of their
supporting the unemployment program
through payment of quarterly taxes so
the number of registered employers is up
about 14 percent when you look at where
we were at the beginning of the pandemic
that first quarter of 2020 a little over
43 000 registered employers to where we
are
currently based on the this data or up
over 52 000 and employers so a lot of
additional demand for a tight supply of
labor
and moving right along
looking at the
taxes and the overall burden on
employers from an unemployment insurance
perspective so employers through their
payment of quarterly taxes support the
unemployment program and the payment of
benefits that go out and what we show
here is how employer and unemployment
taxes what we experience during the
pandemic what has occurred since how
that compared against the Great
Recession and this is all leading to uh
kind of trying to show you the pieces
that contribute to how our unemployment
trust fund is currently doing so here
you can see Great Recession Peak tax
rate employers were up over
3.6 percent that's the rate that they
pay on the first fourteen thousand
dollars in annual wages paid to each
employee so peaked at almost 3.7 percent
had four quarters over 3.3 percent for
the Great Recession you compare that to
the pandemic
um and we peaked it about 2.3 percent so
close to 40 percent below our Great
Recession Peak and those rates have come
down significant significantly and would
be down even more if not for the
substantial increase in new employers
registered with the state and I say that
because when a when an employer comes in
and registers for the first time setting
up their their unemployment account they
are automatically signed a new employer
tax rate of 2.7 percent
um that rate goes up or down based on
their experience in their first four
quarters but that that many new
employers all starting at 2.7 percent
actually
um inflates that average uh tax rate
that you see here of 1.42 so more
established employers are paying at a
much lower rate but it looks a little
bit higher because the the number of new
employers registering at that higher
rate
representative how sticky is that 2.7
percent how long do they have to be in
your good graces before it goes down
significantly uh so so they keep that
2.7 with with one caveat that I'll
explain for the first four quarters
um the one caveat is that if there are
any uh fund balance of reductions so uh
the statutory solvency control for the
trust fund which automatically requires
a reduction in employer rates based upon
the balance in the trust fund if those
kick in in any of those four quarters
that new employer does benefit from
those for instance right now employers
are receiving a half Point fund balance
reduction because the unemployment trust
fund
maintained at least a balance of 250
million dollars during the third quarter
of last year so so and so those positive
rated tax paying employers got a half
Point reduction in the fourth quarter
new employers would also get that so
that 2.7 percent employer would be down
at 2.2 percent
and then uh following years after that
that employer's rate is adjusted based
on their experience so if they've for
some reason had a lot of layoff activity
and we've paid out a lot of benefits
that's a that's a negative against their
experience increasing their rate if they
haven't had any layoff activity we
haven't paid out any benefits but
they've paid their taxes timely then
that's a positive on their rate and that
brings down that experience based rate
so they would be paying less than that
2.7 percent going into that second year
of existence
representative almond
thank you madam chair
could um first if you have an employer
with one employee say a woman with a
nanny uh
just are they
obliged to register and pay this
depending on the the amount of wages
that they're paying to that Nanny yes
if they say that she's working full-time
and she's getting a hundred dollars a
month do you do anything about it
um so the they don't report to us
whether that person is working full-time
or part-time that's not part of the
reporting
um but once they
um exceed a certain number of wages paid
to that individual they're required to
then register and report and pay taxes
on those wages thank you a small
follow-up a rather a larger follow-up on
our on do you have information on how
many of the new employers and the
Employers in general are have more than
10 workers for instance or something
like that we do yes we don't have that
in in these slides but we can certainly
get that to you and get it to the
members of the committee whether that's
changed between the new people and what
um and so moving on here
um
looking at overall tax burden so each
state has a slightly different uh
unemployment insurance tax system
different taxable wage bases experience
is factored differently from state to
state so a great way to compare one
state to the the next in terms of how
much of a overall tax burden is
attributed to on an unemployment
insurance taxes we look at total
unemployment insurance taxes paid as a
comparison against total wages paid and
here you can see New Hampshire
um in that in the red bar at about a
point four percent and how that compares
to other states in the Northeast again
New Hampshire Stacks up very well with
uh with our neighboring states from an
overall tax burden perspective for how
much employers are required to
contribute to the functioning of the
and
um last slide for me and then I'll turn
it over to Brian but all of those
factors so increase in employers
um
low number of claims being filed low
duration of claims being filed you can
see all of that contributes to the
overall health of the unemployment trust
fund right now we're at about 357
million dollars
in that account we started the pandemic
at right at 300 million dollars we have
benefited uh from uh federal dollars
Federal
cares act money that has been
deposited into the trust fund that was
originally designated for other uses not
used for those other other programs but
rather than those dollars go back to the
feds those dollars have been waterfalled
into the unemployment trust fund that's
about 109 million dollars that's gone
into the trust fund so right now we're
at 357 million
um and important to note that that
balance and that that speedy recovery in
the unemployment trust fund has led to
employers getting a tax rate reduction
much faster than originally anticipated
so because the unemployment trust fund
reached and maintained a balance of 250
million dollars during the Third third
quarter of 2022 employers started
receiving a reduction of a half point to
their rate so that 2.7 percent employer
new employer got their rate knocked down
to 2.2 percent uh for the fourth quarter
they will also have that same rate
reduction for the first quarter that
we're currently in the savings that are
forecast for the that rate reduction for
employers over the course of those two
quarters is about 28 million dollars in
savings because of the accelerated pace
which the trust fund has recovered
um and now it's further contributing to
reducing those rates making it less
expensive for those employers to hire
because every employee that they bring
on comes with that cost of paying their
unemployment insurance taxes for the
first fourteen thousand dollars in
annual wages to that employee so all of
uh making things a little bit more
affordable for that employer so I'll
turn it over to Brian now to go on the
next slide we have a few questions if we
could just see if we can address those
first behind you representative McGuire
thank you madam chair thank you for
um I know we in the past we haven't
compared very favorably to other states
on that regard can you talk about that
um we are are not involved in the
administration of the workers comp
program so we're strictly in the
Unemployment Compensation Program so
workers comp is managed by the State
Department of Labor so any questions
that we have on that have to defer to
those folks
representative Platt yes earlier a
discussion about quit rate uh people
voluntarily leaving the labor force how
do you know you you survey employers
because it doesn't show up in the
unemployment lines yeah the um U.S
Bureau of Labor Statistics does a
monthly survey of employers including
Employers in New Hampshire so the quit
representative picture
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question uh we heard this
morning that New Hampshire's participate
participation rate was around 62 percent
nationally it's a little over 70 percent
why is there such a actually it's not
accurate New Hampshire has a higher
labor force participation rate we're
just under 65 around 65 percent we have
been as high as 68 at the peak and labor
force participation rate by the way is
is in part a function of whether people
want to be in the labor force but it's
also a function of the demographics of a
state
people who are very young have lower
participation rates and people who are
older
once get Beyond age 55 participation
rate begins to to slip so depending on
your demographics you're going to have a
higher or lower also it depends on some
of the
socioeconomic characteristics of a
community New Hampshire is about 65
percent nationally it's about 62 percent
it has declined in the nation it's
thank you representative
put a more finer point on that that
is that a 65 is that the difference
between 65 100 are those the people that
are not in the labor force choose not to
be in the labor force have given up
looking for a job that that sort of
thing yeah uh the the way the measure is
calculated is basically you have to be
either employed or actively looking for
work and actively looking for work means
in the prior month have you have you
searched for a job so you will have
people who are marginally attached maybe
occasionally work
um throughout the year they could be
surveyed and indicate that they're not
in the labor force and it's also a
measured traditionally by ages 16 and
above so again if you're counting
everybody age 16 and above the higher
percentage you have in the upper age of
range so above 65 above 75 you're going
to have a lower participation rate there
we have a number of slides that look at
the details of and rich is going to talk
about those details of how it's changed
by demographic group and that's really I
think instructive of of some of the
things that are going on here but I do
want to move a little bit to kind of
where the trends are at the moment and
this is a chart that looks at job
openings again employers are surveyed
and asked about the number of open
positions that they have that they're
actively searching for and this chart
Compares New Hampshire is always the red
line Massachusetts when we compare them
the Blue Line U.S the black line and
what you see is as the recession
um started to ease
the job openings rate jumped and it
jumped for a couple of reasons one
initially a lot of people left the labor
market
um during the pandemic but also there
was a tremendous increase in the quit
rate the churning people were switching
occupations they were switching
Industries so even if you weren't adding
new jobs there was a tremendous need to
hire because there was just a lot of
churn in the labor market and churn in
the labor market is problem for
everybody it's a problem for businesses
very costly so those quit rates by the
way are starting to ease but quit rates
are usually a sign High quit rates are
usually a sign that there's a lot of
opportunities out there and there was
there was following the worst of the
pandemic employers were raising wages
employees were emboldened looking for
better opportunities better working
conditions so there was a lot of
turnover
that said New Hampshire had higher job
openings rate for much of the post
pandemic if there is such a thing period
it has come down
it's come down everywhere but it's still
very strong it's still above what it was
if I go back another 10 or 15 years
you'll see that that rate is
traditionally much lower than it is now
and this is we talked a little bit about
the kinds of occupations that are in
demand this is a really busy chart I
apologize for that this is one you know
before bedtime as a substitute for a
mild sedative or a stiff drink you you
might you might take a look at um
uh but some of the occupations that are
highlighted here in red just gets at
that one issue that we talked about the
medical professions medical occupations
they have traditionally been among the
highest in demand and this compares
the same period in 2019 September
through November to September through
November of 2022 and the number and
change in the demand or the job postings
in New Hampshire for those occupations
and you see the tremendous jump in the
percentage both the numbers and
percentage there so across the board
strong demand in a number of occupations
um that's oh was there a question yes if
representative Edwards behind you
I uh on the previous slide
um I noticed healthcare workers have a
very high growth rate
um overall I'm just curious if your kept
any statistics on it okay how many of
those uh 2022 openings are driven
because they're replacing workers who
were forced out over mandatory vaccine
policies
well well uh let I'll I'll well beyond
my uh pay grade um we don't have that I
don't have any of that data
um so this this data set doesn't capture
that however we do know from
um unemployment claim filings uh that
they were very very few unemployment
claims filed by individuals that uh lost
employment due to a vaccine requirement
thank you
I'm taking a look at the the actual
Trends in job growth this is um a year
Compares year over year job growth um on
a three-month moving average so New
Hampshire right now as of through
November our December numbers will be
coming out next week
um we're about two and a half percent
two point six percent
um private sector job growth
compared to the US which is a little bit
higher I do not believe that it is
because we have a weaker economy than
the national economy I believe it is
because we are more labor constrained we
have had a tighter labor market and I'll
show you a number of
charts that will that will support that
in 2021 we had faster job growth in the
U.S significantly faster
significantly faster in the private
sector but also total non-farm job
growth
this by the way is is Good from one
perspective the Federal Reserve is can
very concerned about inflation it wants
to see the labor market slow down
doesn't want to see job losses but it
wants to see it slow down because it's
concerned about wage wages Rising
rapidly and contributing to inflation so
this is actually a fairly positive trend
um looking at again I say New Hampshire
is not a weaker economy it is just more
labor constrained and this is one way I
measure that again businesses are
surveyed every month how many job
openings they have and how many people
have they hired and that's measured here
as a rate so the job openings rate is
the number of openings plus the number
of people employed in total divided by
that combination of numbers so the
openings rate compared to the hiring
rate is the gap it's the Delta between
how many jobs are available and how many
and the ability to to hire people for
those jobs and what you see here it
jumped again dramatically after the
pandemic indicating the difficulty that
employers have had hiring it was more
difficult for most of this time period
for New Hampshire employers to hire it
is coming down a bit it's coming down
bit because again openings are starting
to ease there's businesses are becoming
a little bit more concerned about
economic prospects moving forward so
they're cutting back a little bit on
big issue that we Face here in New
Hampshire I think the number one issue
that our economy faces is what's
happening with the labor force and our
ability to get more people back into the
labor force or do people who haven't
been into the labor force in the labor
force this chart again New Hampshire the
red line U.S black Massachusetts blue
just indicates compared to the
pre-pandemic peak labor force number of
people in the labor force set a number
of 100
how has it changed and where is it
compared to that Peak number so the US
is back in terms of numbers it to its
pre-pandemic peak not participation rate
but because there's more people even
with a lower rate it can have the same
number of people it has in the labor
forces it did prior to the pandemic New
Hampshire is not there yet we're still
about one percent below our Peak and to
put that into numbers that's almost 8
000 people fewer than we had and our
Peak which was November of
2019. Massachusetts is going in the
opposite direction the wrong direction
New Hampshire by the way took us a long
time to start picking up but we are
picking up we're seeing some pretty good
uh labor force growth over the last
um this is a extremely nerdy chart I
apologize it takes some time but it's my
favorite measure of how tight the labor
market is
most people look at the unemployment
rate as the measure of how tight the
labor market is but that's in part a
function of how many people are actively
looking for work it's not necessarily an
indicator of how many jobs are available
this measure is the employment the
population ratio among what is
considered the prime working age group
age 25 to 54. this is the age group that
has the by far the highest labor force
participation almost you know 90 percent
or more people in that age group are in
the labor force
so when
85 percent of those people in that age
group are employed in New Hampshire I
consider that full employment and this
chart shows you time periods where we've
been above that 85 percent those are
periods of pretty severe labor shortage
just before the pandemic we knew we had
a real significant labor shortages back
in the late 90s we had really severe
labor shortages
in contrast following the Great
Recession you see it dipped well below
that's that seven year period that rich
mentioned in terms of getting back to to
um recovering all of the jobs so we
follow like the U.S fell during the
pandemics the US by the way has a
different demographic so their full
employment is about 80 percent
um but New Hampshire importantly is well
below that 85 what that says to me we've
got a lot of people who are on this on
the sidelines so what I talk to
businesses and they say oh we've got a
2.6 unemployment rate there's nobody to
hire I say no we have this is capacity
utilization we are under utilizing the
capacity of our labor force right now
and our job is really to make that labor
for increase the capacity of utilization
of our labor force as much as it is
getting those unemployed people which we
know is is a small number getting those
people on the sidelines into the into
this may be impossible to answer but as
part of the problem less than full
employment is employers that are overly
picky with the requirements
and maybe soften a little bit and do a
little in-person training
that's a good question I don't know
um I I this is one of those when you
um I think employers have learned some
good lessons about the the problems that
they create for themselves about being
overly picky as you've described it and
also being slow to higher being slow to
make decisions and and the more
successful employers the employers that
have gained employment the sectors that
have gained employment because there's
been some real success stories
throughout the pandemic they've they've
adjusted how they go about doing the
hiring but certainly the old school way
of thinking in terms of constantly
looking at degrees and less focus on
skill sets is something that employers
are really taking a second look at need
to to take a second look at in terms of
overly limiting their candidate pools
and needing to be more focused on skills
rather than degrees but some some of
that sure employers being overly picky
but uh that uh I think they've learned
representatively
I mean our state and neighboring states
but my second thought was
is if this is
based on population of people living in
New Hampshire
um is it possible more folks have chosen
to work in neighboring states and so
that these folks might have jobs that
would be captured in this because
um the the
there's two surveys of employment one is
done of for Employers in New Hampshire
and that measures the number of people
who are actually employed in
organizations in New Hampshire then
there's a household survey which is what
the labor force estimates and the
unemployment rate are based on that
basically calls households and asks
people whether they're employed whether
they're looking for work a whole host of
other issues so this measure of
employment to population
is irrespective of where anybody is
employed
but that to kind of go back to Brian's
statement about the measure that looks
at actual private sector jobs so those
are New Hampshire jobs
um and when you look at the the
information that we have in here you see
that those are those are the the jobs
that are up over where they were prior
to the pandemic and we know those are
New Hampshire based so that's up about a
little over one percent and that's a
great point because sometimes you will
see reports in the media that say
um New Hampshire lost X number of jobs
we've seen that in the last couple of
months when in fact that's not the case
there may be fewer New Hampshire
residents who have jobs but there hasn't
been fewer jobs in New Hampshire and so
you have to make the distinction between
the household survey and the payroll or
employer survey and those two surveys
tend to a lot of times tell different
stories or at least on the surface tell
different stories so Brian and I just
pick the one that looks better
um and we go with that um but usually
when you in in all seriousness usually
when you peel back the layers of the
onion
um in both of those surveys you can find
the consistencies and that they aren't
aren't really telling different stories
um and you can you can better understand
them but there that is a good
distinction between what each one each
one of those is telling you
Senator Rosenwald has a question and
then representative
um do you know to what extent
the people sitting on the sidelines are
disproportionately women who lack access
to child care that makes it
worth going to work
no we do have some indication of that we
don't survey that but during the
pandemic
Census Bureau and the Bureau of Labor
Statistics but primarily the Census
Bureau asked a number of questions of
households about reasons why they
weren't working that were unique and
different from the way we traditionally
had asked those questions they asked
specifically if you
um you know if you weren't working
here are some of the possible reasons
why you aren't looking for work or why
you are and one of them was
uh the need to take care of a child
under the age of one was under the age
of six who did wasn't in school and
didn't have access to child care another
one was ages seven to fourteen whatever
and it wasn't there was an increase so
we do know that that has increased and
we also have anecdotal evidence that
riches we'll talk about eventually that
seems to indicate that it has played a
role there's some gender differences
there particularly among women who are
have are most likely to have the
and I think you're up rich
representative Almy had a quick question
thank you on it's a methodological
question again on Dutch do the does the
labor department and the census
Department do they have access to all of
our cell phones how are they sampling
good question
um
you know I don't know and and my
experience as someone who works closely
with the U.S Bureau of Labor Statistics
anyway
um
not always those kinds of questions can
be difficult to get answers to you will
see about
um you know General sampling procedures
but I have not seen anything that says
particularly
um addresses the issue of cell phones
it's Pro it's problematic in any any
telephone survey for sure and I will
tell you one of the problems that we've
had there's been a lot of data problems
in the pandemic one of the data problems
is that response rates have been
exceptionally low and it's created more
error in the data and we've had the
factors some of that in and as Rich
knows I'm not one of the favorite people
of the Bureau of Labor Statistics
because I ask a lot of questions and I
have concerns about some of the
methodologies in particular with New
Hampshire and the results but but we
don't have an answer for that I'm sorry
we and not having an answer to that is
not due to lack of effort
um so as Brian had indicated I think it
was an understatement we did have some
very interesting conversations with the
Bureau of Labor Statistics throughout
the pandemic
um because we were looking at numbers
that they were were releasing we didn't
feel they were fairly reflective on the
actual state of the labor force in New
Hampshire based on other metrics
um you know we asked for to do things
such as to do a ride along with with the
survey takers just to listen in not not
say anything we keep our mouth shut
um but they just kind of giggled a
little bit when we asked that and uh
they weren't going to have any part of
it so we try to get into the um
what is actually going on with that
monthly survey but it it's really
um you know states are really kind of
um a couple of slides I think getting
into uh
refining some of the data to look at
some of the questions that uh Senator
Rosenwald you've been you've been asking
here
um and we try to get into that we try to
learn more about
um the labor force participation
um falling off from from prior to the
pandemic overall labor force being down
about 8 500 people compared to our
pre-pandemic Peak
um so we we try to look at as much of
the detail as we can to learn a little
bit more about those characteristics
um not just because it's good
information to have but it also shapes
our policies in terms of what we do from
an engagement perspective and trying to
promote re-employment services and
programs and virtual job fairs to
different populations in the state and
trying to grow the labor force so what
you see here is a comparison of some
data that we presented last year when
when we're in front of the The Joint
Committee these with a with the gray bar
and then you see the updated information
in I guess what we would say is an
orange bar but looking at labor force
participation by uh by age cohorts
and
um to highlight a few areas here so when
we were when we were last talking with
the joint committees we had what we
referred to as a bookend problem with
the labor force from a participation
rate perspective we had older workers
who were very slow to come back to the
labor force after the pandemic so our 60
to 69 year old group when you look at
those gray bars in this chart you see
you know 60 to 64 off by nearly 7
percent 65 to 69 off by another three
percent and we go to the other end of
the labor force Spectrum to complete the
that the book ends and you look at our
20 year olds and particularly 25 to 29
was a problematic age group when we last
spoke to you down about five and a half
percent
um now fast forward to where we are now
with the orange line you can see what
has occurred
um during the past year since we last
spoke and you can see when we look again
at those older workers 60 to 69 quite an
improvement uh from a labor force
participation perspective so 60 to 64
year olds going from a seven percent
decline to just over a one percent
decline so significant Improvement and
then our 65 to 69 year olds going from a
three percent decline to a two percent
gain so a five percent swing there so
some significant change improve change
in older workers in their participation
in the labor force over the past year
but when we look at our younger workers
particularly our 25 to 29 year olds and
our 30 to 34 year olds 25 to 29 have
been stubbornly not moving uh very much
when you look at where where they were
from a decline in labor force
participation at 5.5 percent
um just a slight tick of an improvement
down to 5.4 percent so still a
problematic age group from labor force
recovery participation recovery looking
you know compared back to pre-pandemic
and then our 30 to 34 year olds have a
have a a significant
decline in participation when we compare
data that we had last year in the gray
bar to the the more recent data looking
at a little bit over of a three percent
decline in labor force participation
um when we look at what that means from
a numbers perspective so if we you know
we've had as Brian has indicated we've
had our population increases over the
last few years but when you take
pre-pandemic participation rates and you
layer that over those population cohorts
if we had that pre-pandemic
participation we'd be looking at about
an additional 18
000 people participating in the labor
force compared to what we have now uh
the in the the 20 year old group that's
about 9 000 additional people when you
look in the 30 some odd year old group
that's a little over 6 000 additional
people so so both from a percentage
participation perspective and when you
look at the raw numbers of that that is
a significant impact on labor force
recovery and when when we talk to you
about still being down about a percent
um and getting back to that pre-pandemic
Peak and being down about 8 500
individuals participating in the labor
force now you can see where where that
shakes up what age cohorts have been uh
the the most impacted and when we look
at we we break that down a little bit
further trying to get to a point that
Senator Rosenwald had raised looking at
the the prime uh child bearing and
rearing ages when we look at 25 to 34
year olds both labor force participation
and the epop with employment to
population ratio compared by gender you
can see
uh that female participation is off more
than male
um so I'm going to stop you there there
seems to be a lot of interest in this
topic I can see hands trying to be
raised right now and we're also out of
time
so if you don't mind I'm going to
recognize the folks that have questions
and invite you to come to house Ways and
Means again if you're interested if if
you would be interested members
um maybe in the next week or so and that
way we could continue if you have the
time absolutely tell us
um tell us when you want us back and
we'll be more than happy to be there
awesome because obviously there's a lot
of great information in here and I think
there's a lot of good questions
representative Southworth has a question
uh thank you madam chair you might have
just answered it I was trying to match
several slides back the growth and the
professional uh I.T type area with the
Slowdown
um 25 to 29 within my family my nieces
and nephews that are 25 29 are actually
doing great getting some really good
jobs so it doesn't quite match what I've
I mean it it's difficult to
um to say why or on what basis the 25 to
29 year old group has stepped out of
Labor Force we've talked about this a
lot internally it's our one of our our
hypotheses is that there are 25 to 29
year olds who are being compensated in
some fashion
um but they're not what would be
considered or they consider
employed or looking for work they may be
doing gig jobs we joke about uh an
occupation that I had never heard of
people getting paid to play video games
online Apparently that is a thing
but if you have a gig job you're not a w
two wage earner
um and you're getting compensated for
your gig work and somebody from the
government calls you and asks about
whether you're employed and how much
you're earning you may be reluctant to
say yes and so we think that that it's
not the only reason but we do believe
that it's played some role in those
numbers
um I don't think we're actually down
quite that much they clearly are down
um part of that had to do early in the
pandemic with the fact that they've
they've got a lot of stimulus money you
know everybody got four thousand dollars
that younger cohort is was most likely
to be employed more likely to be
employed in the industries that had the
biggest layoffs they received a lot of
um you know both compensation from the
state unemployment but also from the
federal government so I gave them a
cushion to stay out of the labor force a
little bit longer and we heard that a
lot anecdotally now that's run out so
representative Edwards has a question
[Music]
CEO the underground economy or the black
market of employment these are people
who make their living by doing illegal
activities or do housekeeping or
something else in the margins that are
just cash basis with their employer do
we have any statistics are we doing any
data collection around the size and
scope of New Hampshire's underground
economy
um so
similar to prior to the pandemic and and
here here we are in 2023
um
we capture for in terms of employment
that which is compensated on a W-2
that's what's reported to us on the on
the quarterly census of employment wages
uh so to the extent that that existed
prior to the pandemic
um as I am sure that it did hence why
several agencies have Auditors that are
traveling the state occasionally to talk
to employers and why we get blocked
unemployment claims from people who file
and then uh don't have any wages on
record and we have to determine what's
going on I'm sure that is still uh going
on but the uh participate the
participation drop off
um here I would
we theorize is more attributed to that
non-traditional but still perfectly
legal
type of employment albeit compensated by
a 1099 and not a traditional covered
employment situation of W-2 type
employment now there might be an
opportunity to be able to compare some
of that with 1099 activity we've talked
about that and there might be as we do
experience that a Slowdown in 2023 there
might be a more of a movement back to
what is perceived as more stable
traditional employment as well which
could drive some of that non-traditional
employment but legal
internet-based gig type of work maybe
back to traditional employment but the
to the extent that there's uh the cash
type of economy and that is
um
part of the situation well that you know
that that existed prior to the pandemic
to the extent it continues to exist
I shut you off completely I just
realized that I don't see our next
presenter is Dr Kenneth Johnson here you
are wonderful okay thank you for your
patience so ah yes representative
spillsburg we've got a couple quick
questions and then we'll wrap it up
thanks thank you madam chairman uh
before we have our guests return I would
love to have this slide Set uh sent as
an email attachment so I can absorb the
Glorious color and get more out of it
than I did from the miniaturized version
everything you've received today is in
an email in the link and on the website
so please go look back at your email
from Miss jennifer4 and you will find
all of these attachments in full color
but there'll be spoiler alerts if you
look at it because we were going to give
you our forecasts and now you're gonna
the spoiler alert there's no reason for
us to come back we may actually have an
opening in our schedule next Tuesday
afternoon if you could check yours let
us know I have a feeling both of our
schedules are open during whatever time
you have available we'd love to hear
that thank you so much
thank you thank you thank you to be
continued
awesome well then we will uh recommend
uh recognize Dr Kenneth Johnson
Dr Johnson is a senior demographer at
the car seats School of Public Policy
professor of Sociology at the University
of New Hampshire and at iron and and on
Andrew Carnegie fellow sorry about that
welcome
foreign
please use the microphone so we can hear
you better thank you so much sorry thank
you
so this is the difficult time to be a
demographer although the 2020 census is
done there's been delays in the release
of the data from it so that complicates
my job of trying to talk to you about
what's going on right now but I'll do
the best I can
I just like to acknowledge the funding
agencies who supported my research
and one thing that's going to come out
in the in the data that we're going to
see is that long term the population
gains to the state of New Hampshire have
diminished New Hampshire is not growing
as much as it was during the 70s 80s 90s
but in the short term it's actually
grown modestly
and when I'm when I talk about what's
going on in New Hampshire there are
different elements different demographic
elements to it
on the one hand there's natural change
which I'll sometimes call natural
increase or natural decrease which is
the difference between the number of
births and deaths that occur in the
state
and then the other big factor and this
is increasingly important in New
Hampshire is net migration which is the
difference between the number of people
who move into New Hampshire and the
number of people who leave New Hampshire
and I'll talk about two different kinds
of migration one is domestic migration
which is people coming to New Hampshire
from other U.S destinations
and the other is immigration which is
people coming from another country
so
this is just recent Trends this is 2010
to 2020 so this is from the U.S census
you can see that New Hampshire was the
second fastest growing of the New
England states after Massachusetts
and one thing I want to draw your
attention to and this will become a
common theme the gray bar that you can
see for New Hampshire is migration
that's the difference between the number
of people who moved to New Hampshire and
the number of people who left
and you can see that the primary source
of population growth in New Hampshire is
migration the orange bar is natural
increase the difference between the
number of deaths and the number of burrs
and you can see that that's very modest
compared to the migration as a factor so
this is the newest data that we have and
these are estimates so they are subject
to some variability but they'll they're
generally accurate and you can see again
this is New Hampshire from the Census in
April of 2020 to July of 2022 which is
the newest data that's available
and you can see that again migration
fueled all of the growth in New
Hampshire and in fact that more people
died in New Hampshire than were born now
in part this is a function of covid
which increased the number of deaths in
New Hampshire as it did as you can see
in New England and almost all the New
England states there were more deaths
than birth and actually in the United
States more generally 24 States had more
people dying and then be born in the
last year that's way more than has ever
happened in the past the highest number
of states to have more deaths than
bursts in U.S history is five and that
was in 2019 before that it would be
unusual for more than one or two states
to have more people die and then be born
so covet is a big factor here but New
Hampshire actually had more people dying
in it than being born even before covet
so migration is the driving force in
demographic change in New Hampshire as
you can see here as well
these are long-term trends for New
Hampshire you can see the 70s and 80s
when the population was growing
dramatically
and again here in those earlier years
it's a function of both migration and
natural increase that was fueling the
growth of New Hampshire's population as
we get into the more recent periods
population change slows in New Hampshire
and then again you can see for 2010 to
2020 that um it was all driven by
migration and it was relatively small
growth
these are more recent data
and I wanted you to see the effect of
the recession and the aftermath of the
recession on New Hampshire demographic
Trends and then what's happened since
then so 2010 to 2015 although the
economists would tell you that the
recession was over in 2010 it certainly
wasn't and even the economists who were
just there before me made a point of
showing you that the impact of the
recession went on well into the 2010 to
2020 period it didn't demography too you
can see in New Hampshire
that early in the period just after the
recession ended that migration to New
Hampshire had slowed down particularly
domestic migration the orange bar
as we get into the later part of the
decade migration picked up but you can
see that there's very little actually
natural decrease began and then in the
in the most recent two and a half years
or two and a quarter years you can see
the uptick in migration domestic
migration in particular that is people
coming to New Hampshire from other U.S
destinations
and also we had modest immigration but
natural decrease the excess of bursts
over deaths the Red Bar I'm sorry the
excess of deaths over Burrs produced
population loss so literally all of New
Hampshire's population gained in the
last two and a half years has been from
migration
now this is an important slide and one
that I
I would hope that if you're going to
remember one thing from this talk this
would be one of the things I'd like you
to remember when I talk about migration
I'm usually talking about net migration
which is the difference between the
number of people moving into New
Hampshire and the number of people
leaving New Hampshire if you look at the
domestic migration that middle set of
bars that little gray bar which is the
amount of domestic migration net is a
function of almost 250 000 people moving
into New Hampshire and 215
000 people leaving New Hampshire in
other words there's a lot of turnover in
New Hampshire's population and I think
that's something that's often not
recognized that that little bit of net
change is the function of a lot of
people coming and a lot of people going
from the state you can also see the
number of births and deaths that were
going on that produce that modest loss
this is 2015-19
and then you can see immigration as well
so again when we talk about net change
in New Hampshire's population recognize
that a lot of the people who are here
are gone and a lot of new people are
here
this is birth and deaths in New
Hampshire you can see the
the fall off and the number of births in
New Hampshire which began during the
Great Recession and has continued on
there has been essentially no recovery
in the birth rates from the Great
Recession during the Great Recession the
birth rates dropped quite dramatically
in the United States not just in New
Hampshire and there has been little if
any evidence of recovery in those birth
rates
so the number of births in the United
States is quite low uh compared to what
it would have been had the birth rates
that were common in the United States at
the time of the Great Recession
continued my estimate is that about 8
million fewer babies have been born in
the United States over the last 15 years
or so that would have been born you can
also see the gradual increase in the
death rates in New Hampshire that's
primarily a function of the Aging of New
Hampshire's population but of course you
can see covid's effect near the end of
that period
so I talked to you about migration in
New Hampshire and I I I wanted to talk
about this a little bit more only 41 of
the people who are living in New
Hampshire were born in New Hampshire 41
only three states have a smaller
proportion of their population born in
the state
New Hampshire has a lot of population
that comes from other U.S destinations
and you can see that in the red bar on
the right hand side which shows New
Hampshire the place of birth in New
Hampshire's current residence New
Hampshire has a very modest number of
foreign-born
people
and then you can compare that to New
England and to the United States more
generally and you can see the striking
difference in the proportion of New
Hampshire's population that was born
somewhere else in the United States
so for all of the people who think that
this is where I mean that who remember
the west wing and Jeb Bartlett who'd
been in New Hampshire for what 10
Generations somebody had signed the
Declaration of Independence
New Hampshire is not really like that it
has a very large proportion of its
population born else how many of you
yes
there are still owning businesses here
they're still doing all the things that
people do in New Hampshire this is where
New Hampshire domestic migrants that is
people moving within the United States
come from and as you can see the largest
source of in-migrants to New Hampshire
is Massachusetts in fact 23 percent of
the people who live in New Hampshire
were born in Massachusetts
uh and then on the right hand side you
can see when people leave New Hampshire
where they go some go to Massachusetts
many more go to the Sun Belt than come
from the Sun Belt
this is the population by age and you
can see in these data that a large part
of the working age population in
particular was born elsewhere in the
United States that is in New Hampshire
so when we were talking about the
working age population in this state a
lot of them are from somewhere else in
the United States relatively modest
numbers are immigrants from other
countries
this is the educational attainment of
New Hampshire benefits from migration a
substantial proportion of the population
moving into New Hampshire is well
educated you can see that in the gra on
the right hand size of the graphs these
are the number of college graduates and
graduate people with graduate degrees in
New Hampshire and that 41 percent of New
Hampshire's population I told you was
born in the state of the population over
the age of 20
25 only 32 percent less than a third of
the adult population in New Hampshire
was born here so migration is a really
important part of what happens in New
Hampshire as you can see
these are age-specific migration data
the latest data the red bars are still
still provisional we're still working on
these data
but they tell a story of who comes to
New Hampshire and who leaves New
Hampshire and you can see consistently
that New Hampshire gains people in their
30s and 40s in their Prime working age
that's those up bars that you can see
and they also and their children come
with them of course and so you can see
the influx of children and the influx of
working age family age adults New
Hampshire has in some decades
experienced a loss of young adults as
far as we can tell in the last decade
between 2010 and 2020 that didn't happen
the number of young adults moving into
and out of New Hampshire was essentially
even and so New Hampshire essentially
retained about the same number of people
in their 20s as
as would have been here uh
otherwise now also another stereotype
about New Hampshire is that lots of
older adults move to New Hampshire and
you can see there is a modest influx of
older adults to the state but it's not
as if everybody in Massachusetts packs
up a U-Haul and moves here when they
retire so again this is the age
structure of the population and the
migration patterns in the state
and again many states would do anything
to have a age-specific migration profile
like this where they're receiving lots
of people in their Prime working age
groups well-educated people in those age
groups and holding on to almost all of
their 20-something year olds
just to give you some idea of what kind
of implications this has
this shows you the number of children
who are born in New Hampshire the blue
bar and the number of children who begin
first grade in New Hampshire six years
later and you can see consistently more
kids begin the first grade in New
Hampshire than were born in the states
six years previously in other words
that's those parents coming to New
Hampshire with their children
so New Hampshire all those New Hampshire
school enrollment clearly is declining
as you can see
um this influx of working age people and
their children helps to keep the number
of children uh in New Hampshire in the
school system
I can stop here for a minute if anybody
has questions about that part of my talk
before I go on
I just want to keep an eye on time just
so you know I promise we'd be done at
three just so you know representative
Petrie has a question
I'm Sharon thank you for
great presentation uh in the last uh
probably 10 years we've lost 25 percent
of our public school students you know
not lost but the enrollments have
diminished by 25 by that much how do we
you know maintain labor force for that
unless we have immigration
I mean uh have you studied that area
right I mean it is migration that helps
New Hampshire keep sufficient young
working age people to staff its
employment structure
and we I mean what are we going to do
about it I mean migration will that you
think that will maintain uh our
Workforce
I would say I mean given the age
structure profiles of the population
migrating into New Hampshire that is an
important contributor to the to the size
of the labor force whether it will
offset the decline in the number of
children I mean that's a question for a
labor Economist not for a demographer
yes do you have a question
I'm interested in that
the 20 to 29 that did not leave the
state in the last decade I know that
we've had a number of students leave the
state for for affordable higher
education elsewhere can you explain that
significant change in the last decade
that the 20th year old has been saying
right now again remember that we're
looking at the the balance of the flow
in and out of the state so there are
going to be a lot you have to face
forward so you're into the mic there
there's going to be a lot of
20-somethings leaving the state but
in the last decade roughly the same
number came to the state so it's that
balance which produced that lack of loss
in that period
the data are so new that we I haven't
had time to actually try and understand
exactly what's driving that or if to
what extent we can so
but again I I
it's important to recognize that there
are big flows under any one of these
nets so
now as you all know from being in New
Hampshire demographic change varies
across the state this shows you the 2010
to 2020 decade uh
and Compares it to 20 2000 to 2010. now
you can see overall there's less growth
in the state there's less of the Blues
and dark greens but the patterns are
fairly similar that is you can see that
there's more uh growth in the southeast
part of the state and less growth in the
northern part of the state in both
periods so the overall growth slowed in
2010 to 2020 compared to the earlier
decade but the patterns are fairly
similar in where the growth was and
where the decline was
just to give you a little better idea I
wanted to show you some of the counties
so I'm going to focus on Three Counties
Hillsboro Carol and koas
and these are this is showing you the
amount of population change the Red Bar
the blue bar is natural increase and the
gray bar is migration and so you can see
that these Counties have very different
profiles in how they've grown or
declined
so let me focus in on them so you can
see for example in Hillsborough County
that the population growth has occurred
through a combination of natural
increase more burst than deaths and also
for migration
so those two things together fueled
modest growth in Hillsborough County in
contrast Carroll County which is a
recreational and amenity County
experiences all of its growth for
migration
now this has come there are about 300
counties like Carroll around the United
States which are big recreational or
amenity counties and this is a very
typical profile for them that is they
receive lots of migrants many of them
older adults
near retirement age
but they have relatively modest sized
populations of childbearing age and that
plus the influx of older adults who
eventually will have higher mortality
produces natural decrease now of course
this was accelerated these these data
don't show the covid period but they
were accelerated by the onset of covid
and the other thing that
is interesting here is that in the in
the period of the pandemic
we have seen in the United States
generally and in New Hampshire in
particular at least originally in the
first year of the pandemic there was an
inflow of migrants to recreational and
amenity counties in some cases they were
people moving to their second homes they
already owned and staying in the more
because of the flexibility of work or
because of their concerns with the
pandemic
in other cases it may have been people
taking advantage of the flexibility of
work to move to a place where they had
accessed outside amenities and
Recreation and many of them have prior
experience in these places so this was
very common in the early stages of the
of the pandemic it's a little unclear
how much of that is continuing we've
been looking at cell phone data and
other kinds of of data change of address
data and it suggests that that
tendency may have slowed in the second
year of the pandemic but we just don't
we don't have enough data yet at the
county level to be able to do that to
tell for sure but anyway that's and then
koas County the most northern County and
the in the state experiences substantial
natural decrease and in part this kind
of natural decrease that's going on in
coax County and a lot of other counties
like it is a function of the long-term
outflow of young adults from the labor
from the counties in other words people
in their 20s tend to leave counties like
these older people stay over time as the
number of young people keep leaving and
the older population ages in place there
are relatively few young women of
childbearing age to produce children and
there are more more older adults at high
risk of mortality who began to die and
so that's the kind of impact that you
can see in a county like koas so even in
a small state like New Hampshire you can
see very different demographic
Tendencies playing out over this over
the the state
this is and then here I focus in on just
Hillsborough County so that you can see
Manchester and Nashua compared to the
rest of Hillsborough County which I call
the Suburban areas I'm sure if I were to
say that in Hillsborough County there
would be objections to that in some
places but just bear with me and you can
see the very different patterns in
Manchester and Nashua which depend
primarily on natural increase to fuel
the increases in their population
compared to the suburbs which are
experiencing more migration into them
and also have some natural increase now
these patterns would be very consistent
with what you would see in urban areas
around the United States larger urban
areas as well that is that they depend a
lot on natural increase and that they
experience relatively low levels of
migration or out in many big urban areas
they may actually experience out
migration particularly we interrupt for
a quick question representative a bit of
a quick statement I'm from glasstown in
Hillsborough County one of those suburbs
and you said nothing objectionable good
I'm glad
I always feel like I'm walking on eggs
when I lump groups together so
any other questions about this before I
this is this is age specific
change in the New Hampshire population
New Hampshire's population is aging
that's no surprise to any of you you
know you've heard that before but I just
wanted to show you how that process is
going on so these are three different
decades the blue bar is the 1990s the
red bar is the 2000s and the green bar
is 2010 to 2019. we don't have the data
at this level of detail from the 2020
Census Data yet
and I got I want to show you two
different cohorts
that the Blue Core the one that's
labeled at the top with the blue arrows
those are people who were born between
1950 and 1959 in other words the heart
of the baby boom New Hampshire received
a big influx of baby boom era people
over the period from the 1970s forward
and they've aged and so you can see over
the course of the three decades them
moving from being in their 40s to being
in their 50s to being in their 60s and
how the population in that age group
grew in New Hampshire as they moved
through the age structure in contrast
the population born in the 1970s who
were the children actually of the baby
boom
and you may remember that if you are a
member of the baby boom that your own
parents kind of grudgingly waited for
you to have children a little bit later
than they had
there was a lag in the number of babies
being born at that time those are
relatively small cohorts and you can see
as they move through the age structure
there's a drop in the size of those age
groups as they move from being in their
20s to into their 30s to into their 40s
and so you can see the shifting of New
Hampshire's age structure here with the
increase in the older part of the age
structure and declines in the small in
the in the young adult part of the age
structure as these cohorts move through
this is a population pyramid that
demographers use to illustrate the
population the red side
is women the blue side is men this is
the age structure in 1990 so this
youngest babies born between 1986 and
1990 are the ones at the very bottom who
are zero to four
and the one of those big baby boom
cohorts born between 1956 and 60. you
can see them in their 30s
and so this is what the age structure of
New Hampshire looked like in 1990 I'm
going to let you see it age ahead now so
you can see what it looks like now
notice that the average age in New
Hampshire in 1990 was 32.8
here it here's that same age structure
in 2000 people are aging in place plus
the migration streams are coming and
going
the population gets older that little
cohort that you saw that was born uh
that was zero to four in the last slide
now is 10 to 14 and that's 76 to 80
cohort that when I told you that was
small because there hadn't been as many
births in that period you can see that
notch in the pyramid where they are and
then the Baby Boomers are now in their
40s here's the same pyramid in 2010
see the population aging median age is
now 41 up from 32 in 1990 and those
cohorts are moving up through the age
structure and then finally this is the
newest data that we have and you can one
of the things I want you to see is how
big those cohorts that were the Baby
Boomers were in the now in their 50s and
60s and early 70s how big they are 214
000 in the cohort 60 to 69 and 183 000
in the cohort 50 to 59 and then notice
how much smaller the cohorts behind them
are
so that it's that that bulge is coming
up through the age structure
and is the result of New Hampshire's
population
getting older now as you saw from the a
specific migration data it's not as if
huge numbers of older adults are
flooding into New Hampshire it's the
Aging in place of New Hampshire's
thank you does this imply a a shrinking
population going forward and when should
we start seeing it based on that data a
lot depends on what happens with
migration
you can see already that the
the growth of that age structure
of that older age structure is going to
increase mortality in the state there
are relatively few women of childbearing
age and New Hampshire's birth rate is
relatively low
so the number of children being born is
diminishing and so
there will be continuing natural
decrease that is more deaths than birth
in New Hampshire in the future whether
the population of the state will grow or
not depends on migration particularly
domestic migration but also to a lesser
just and again
there's a lot of variability within New
Hampshire so this is the youngest these
are the children in New Hampshire
on the left hand side is What proportion
of the communities are children and on
the right hand side is the actual number
of children in those areas so you can
see for example in the southeast part of
the state not only are a large
proportion of the larger proportion of
the population children that yellow
or orange but also that's where a lot of
the children are now again I know this
is no news to you but it just shows you
how much variability there is within the
state and for a legislature that has to
think about a whole state
I just want to hope that you recognize
that there is such striking variability
even within the state
this is the working age population or
six
18 to 64 anyway and again you can see
the same patterns that is that there
there's more of a concentration in the
Southeast and the mid part of the state
than in the north and again it's not
just the distribution by percentages
which is what the left-hand graph is
showing What proportion of the
population is in this age group you can
also see in the right hand map where the
population literally is
and then this is the older population
and you can see that there are
differences that the population on
average is older in the northern part of
the state than it is in the southern
part of the state
but the most older adults in New
Hampshire are in the southern part of
the state because that's where most of
the population is
so this is going to create challenges
for agencies and units that are
age-based for example school systems in
the northern part of the state may be
worried about closing schools or cons
even the dreaded word of consolidating
school districts which sets people on
edge everywhere
but those same places may have growing
numbers of older adults which are going
to put other demands on local government
and state agencies for for things in
that in that age group so there's a lot
of diversity within this state on age
both in where the numbers are and how
the population is distributed
this this is just one this is one more
point I wanted you to make you'll often
hear about how New Hampshire is the
oldest or one of the oldest states in
the country and I just wanted to show on
two different measures the upper measure
is the percentage of the population over
65. and you can see that New Hampshire
is about eighth in terms of the
population over 65. the median age in
New Hampshire is the second highest and
that's primarily because so much of the
New Hampshire population is in the baby
boom cohorts and so that big block of
people raises the median age in the
state so
New Hampshire certainly has an older
population out where it stands in
comparison other states depends in part
on how you measure it
questions about this part before I move
on
sorry I I know you should be doing that
okay
diversity now you've all heard New
Hampshire's not very diverse
and in fact it is among the least
diverse states in the United States but
its diversity is increasing and I think
that has important implications for many
issues that come before the state
legislature this is the diversity of new
of the United States population by
County so this is the chances that two
people who meet randomly on the street
would be of different racial or ethnic
groups
and so the yellows and the oranges are
the most diverse parts of the United
States and the blues and the greens are
the least diverse parts of the United
States so you can see on a graphic like
this that Northern New Hampshire
Northern New England is not exactly uh
among the most diverse parts of the
country
this is a close-up that shows you just
New England and you can see the striking
difference between the southern states
and New England and the northern part of
New England
there is some diversity as I'll show you
but it it does vary
this is New Hampshire's population in 20
from the 2020 census so this is the
racial breakdown and ethnic breakdown of
the state and the way this is set up the
white population is the non-hispanic
white population now there's a lot of
different ways that diversity can be
measured but the one that's used most by
demographers is to treat non-hispanic
whites and in fact non-hispanics as
racial groups but treat Hispanics as
another group now the way the Census
Bureau actually asks the question is a
little different than this
and Hispanics would be very unhappy
about all being lumped into one category
like this uh just like when you used to
put Italians and swedes in the same
category you'd have problems but anyway
that's just the way these data are
defined so this is the population of New
Hampshire about 12.8 percent of New
Hampshire's population is minority that
is it's not non-hispanic white
but here's a key point
between 19 2010 and 2020 all of the
growth all of the growth in New
Hampshire's population was minority the
white non-hispanic white population of
New Hampshire actually got smaller
between 2010 and 2020 slightly smaller
so all the growth in the population came
from minorities only the even though
they only represented 12.8 percent of
the population they produced all the
population increase
and another key point and this is true
not just in New Hampshire but all over
the United States the most diverse part
and so you can see the Striking contrast
here 20 over 20 percent of New
Hampshire's child population is minority
but only 11 percent of it's an adult
population so the diversity is coming to
New Hampshire from the bottom up so any
agency or
organization that deals with children is
going to face diversity
earlier or more more frequently than
older groups are
so I have a daughter who's a
pediatrician in a hospital
and not in New Hampshire but in the
Midwest and she will often tell me that
when people come into the hospital often
the children have to translate for the
parents and she said it puts them in an
I mean you can imagine the awkward
position with the questions that doctors
would have to ask
about but I mean you can just see it's
one way that this is going to play out
is with the child population being the
most diverse
um
it has lots of implications for schools
so again just a key Point diversity is
greater among the child population
and that's true all over the United
States not just here the most diverse
part of the population of the babies
that have just been born in the United
States the least diverse are the people
at the oldest age groups so in New
Hampshire about 88 percent of the births
are non-hispanic white 98 of the deaths
are non-hispanic white may we interrupt
for a quick question right behind you
representative Edwards yes thank you
madam chair I'm just curious what other
is Mike as I'm sitting here guessing I'm
thinking it's multi-racial or just
unknown data it's small yes it's
multi-racial it's a native alaskans and
Hawaiians it's people
um
knowledge on everyone's race in the
state or is there how how big is your
unknown or your fudge back these data
come directly from the Census so they're
the self-reported race of each
individual who filled out a census
questionnaire
which was filled out by approximately
this is the change in New Hampshire's
population between 2000 and 2019. so
this is a 20-year period and it shows
the changes in the different age groups
within the population so the number of
white children has diminished the number
of minority children increased modestly
I mean you can see the graph the point
would be that the growth of the white
population is primarily in the older
population
while the number of children who are
non-hispanic white has diminished this
would be this trend would be similar in
other parts of the United States as well
this is the distribution of the
population
uh by minority status
in the state in 2020 according to the
census and so you can see that if you
look at the population as a whole the
minority population is primarily
concentrated in some areas of the state
and there are other parts of the state
which have very little minority
population if you look at this for
children and adults separately you can
see the change coming to different parts
of the state that is the green is the
least diverse and the oranges and reds
are the most diverse but you can see the
difference how more much more widespread
diversity is among the child population
than it is among the adult population so
this just underscores again the fact
that change is coming even though New
Hampshire is much less diverse in the
nation as a whole it's becoming more
diverse Through Time
and if you folk I'm going to focus now
on just the corridor that you can look
you can see in the map from Nashua to
Manchester this is the racial breakdown
of that Corridor and so there are areas
in Manchester and Nashua which are as
diverse as big urban areas are
right I mean you've got areas where the
child the particularly of the child
population where over 40 percent of the
population is minority now you can
imagine the challenges this produces for
agencies and school districts that have
to deal with a diverse population and
again for people who are not from parts
of the state that are diverse recognize
that even in a state like New Hampshire
there are some very diverse parts of the
population
any any questions about that before I go
on
okay that defer the diversity is not
just about race diversity spans a lot of
different dimensions this is this is New
England this is education and income
where the oranges and reds are the
highest education highest income areas
and the greens are the least here is
just New Hampshire so you can see it
and you can see that there are large
areas of New Hampshire which have
extremely well-educated high-income
populations and other parts of the state
which have more modest income
distributions and where uh higher
this is educational attainment by uh by
among adults these are adults 25 and
over by race and Hispanic origin
so again you can see that there's quite
a bit of variability from the Asian
population which is relatively small but
has an extremely high education level
to other groups where education levels
are not as high or are more evenly
distributed
so again my point is just that there's a
diversity along among a variety of
different characteristics this is income
so you can see variability and income
distributions as well from families that
are earning relatively low incomes of
fifty thousand or less up to very well
uh high-income families
and how they distribute
this is New Hampshire is very fortunate
in that it has either the lowest or the
second lowest poverty rate in the United
States particularly for children but
that doesn't mean that there isn't
poverty in the state and that it doesn't
vary across the state both by race and
ethnicity
and by poverty by geography so there are
areas of the state particularly for
children that are have relatively High
poverty rates and other parts of the
state where poverty for children is
relatively
unknown
so again my point here is just that
there's diversity in the state along a
variety of gradients from population to
age to race to income so
even though it's a small state it is
remarkably diverse along a number of
different dimensions
one last point
I want you to notice that the
demographer is going to finish on time
why do people move to and why do they
stay in New Hampshire we've done a lot
of research on this uh and this is with
my graduate student now PhD Christine
um
we asked we didn't use check boxes we
actually asked a large cross-section of
New Hampshire residents
to tell us in their own words why they
stayed in New Hampshire or if they moved
here recently why they moved to New
Hampshire and these are the answers we
got so you can see that family reasons
and that varies if it's older adults
it's because they want to be close to
their grown children or their
grandchildren if it's younger families
they want to be close to their their
parents so that they can have help with
child care and all the other things that
come with being a young parent but
family was an important reason the
natural environment the beauty of New
Hampshire the access to lakes and
mountains we're all very attractive both
to Residents who have been here for a
long time and for recent arrivals
quality of life which they meant they
felt safe they felt that they were part
of a community was another factor and
then you can see employment and taxes
culture
all kinds of other factors and one
important point we found also was that
people don't come here or stay here for
only one reason they come or stay for a
variety of reasons so it's not any one
of these things
that brings people to New Hampshire or
keeps them here it's a combination of
them
and given how important migration is to
the state's future
I think it's important that we recognize
that there are these multi-faceted
things that cause people to come to the
state or stay and again when you think
about growing New Hampshire there's two
ways you can do it you can attract
people to the state but you can also
retain more of your people you can lose
fewer of them and that's going to keep
the population I mean that's going to
keep the losses from going down as
migration into the state
increases so just
migration as I said migration is
important to New Hampshire again I want
to emphasize do people don't come to New
Hampshire or stay in New Hampshire for
just one reason they're influenced by a
variety of factors so policies aimed at
both attracting people or retaining
people are going to be something that
will help New Hampshire
so for example when you talk about
making New Hampshire attractive to
families that's about the quality of
Education that's about access to child
care all of those kinds of factors are
important
if you're talking about uh the state the
beauty of the state that's preserving
the state's natural resources that's
improving the parks that's committing
more resources to conservation
um again
recognize that there's a lot of
different facets to this
so just in conclusion
population and growth has slowed
compared to what it was in the previous
decades we're not people are not
flooding into the state the way they
were in the 70s and 80s and 90s
the most recent census data we have
suggests that there is a significant
amount of domestic migration going into
the state that people are coming to New
Hampshire from other places in the
United States we don't have as much
immigration but there's still a modest
we we talked a little bit about how
there are fewer births going on right
now and there are more deaths because of
covet now again that happened started to
happen before covid so even as the
deaths from covets diminish as they are
now it's not as if we're going to return
to a unless there's some remarkable
change in women's childbearing Behavior
we're not going to have another baby
boom that's going to produce a lot of
child growth in New Hampshire
I I wanted you to see the demographic
change in New Hampshire is uneven
some areas are growing other areas are
declining some some school districts are
going to worry about opening a new
school other students other school
districts are going to have to worry
about how can they consolidate two
elementary schools into one
diversity is growing in the state but it
remains largely non-hispanic and white
and New Hampshire's population is aging
so just some final implications that
migration is important is an important
source of human capital for the state
the people who come to the state are
well educated
um
they some of them are bringing children
with them as well
the state needs both to attract those
people but also to retain its existing
population not lose them
the ver we talked about diversity
remaining modest again remember that
diversity is greatest for the youngest
and least among the oldest of the
population the population change
patterns are uneven in the state
some State some places are going to have
to cope with expansion and growth others
are going to have to deal with
contraction which in many ways is more
difficult for places to deal with and
the growing older population is going to
produce a lot of challenges for the
state
so thank you very much
if you have any questions I'd be happy
to answer them
thank you madam chair
um do you track at all the um the
reasons that people leave the state I
wish we could it's it's a hard I mean if
you think about the way we we use the
granite state poll which is a University
of New Hampshire polling organization
which takes a poll of the state every
three months we put our questions on
about 12 or 15 of their surveys they
reach the people of the state reaching
the people who leave is a lot more
difficult to do it's not impossible but
it's a lot more difficult so we know
less about why people leave than why
they come
representative Army
at today and it seems to me that there's
a major split in the Hispanic and black
sectors of the of the population
the Hispanics and blacks have higher
family income and higher
um
educational attainment but when you turn
to the next page and you're looking at
poverty levels they also have the higher
poverty levels
right
I mean they they don't have as high
income levels as other racial groups but
they have moderately High poverty levels
a part of the question would be which
parts of the population
I mean it it's possible that the parts
of the population with relatively
um High income are not the parts that
have a lot of children either yet or
their children are grown so
I haven't looked in detail at it
um I just like to apologize I can't read
the small print on these things I'm
sorry this is the percentage of people
in that group right is higher
on
with educational attainment then then
the percentage of people in a white
group for instance
okay which is a somewhat different thing
at least the baby boom big enough to
where we need to start worrying about
yes I've been asked this question a
number of times at a number of different
levels of geography there there was a
slight uptick in birth in New Hampshire
last year New Hampshire again has low
birth rates there was an uptick in burst
last year but the number of births
declined again this year so
um
there is no evidence of a baby boom
either in New Hampshire or at the
national level
um
people I mean I got questions from the
national media a lot about this
um here are all these people at home
with nothing else to do
are we going to have a baby boom
uh demographers generally said no it's
not going to happen and in fact it
didn't happen I mean there
so there hasn't been a baby boom
representative McGuire behind you has a
question
related to that
um when do we know how many births there
were in 2022
we know that now is that we we have
preliminary data
for the period from
um for the first half of 2022 and the
number of births in the first half of 22
are down slightly from what they were in
2021.
yeah
we I mean there's always a lag and when
birth data is reported
um I mean it's a problematic in a state
like New Hampshire in particular because
some births that are to New Hampshire
residents will occur in hospitals in
Massachusetts and it takes a while for
it's more of a statement but um I was a
State Registrar in 2008 and I retired
you know towards 2009 and when I was
registered we had 15 000 births and 9
500 deaths so you can't blame this on me
and uh regarding the birth enumeration
we we actually developed a program
called Nevin Webb and if you're looking
at just events of birth death marriage
divorce and Fetal death it's immediately
reported
um as the
you know as the event occurs so if you
want to Google you know never in web you
can create a login and check out I
actually use that quite often excellent
well but that's one thing you can thank
me for but I mean it was actually not
really well received because people
thought that it may need time to like
ripen the data
but um it became lauded after a while
because it was just immediate access to
to data like that so anyway
Senator Lang
representative McGuire
representative McGuire so the Office of
Vital Statistics right I believe it's in
the Secretary of State's office I'll get
you the most current data if you just
ask them they're they've been really
good
what's available how many births
you can um essentially well with regard
to the bursts that occur like out of
state it may take a while to to grab
those but for the events that occurred
in New Hampshire
um you would get them within a day as
the hospital reports it you you have
you're welcome sorry a lot of the my
answer was coming mostly from nchs the
national Center for Health statistics
because I'm not looking just at New
Hampshire but at a lot of other states
too
excellent presentation thank you so much
and your time management is exceptional
but your data's Got Fabulous too thank
you so much everyone enjoy I hope you
all enjoy this as much as I did I will
look to see you at 9am tomorrow
hopefully tomorrow's a little bit
shorter day though hopefully we'll be
done by noon 12 30 at the latest thanks
we have this room tomorrow so if you
want to leave your binders and stuff
here you can leave it right on the table
in front of your name tag